you
good morning everyone
welcome to the monday
april 11th edition
of the science technology and energy
committee public hearing session we're
going to hear
or we're going to have public hearings
on six different bills today
and before we begin
i'd like us all to rise and join
representative bernardi in the pledge of
allegiance of america
to the republic for which it stands on
one nation under god indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
all right thank you before we begin i'll
just remind everyone that if you want to
speak on any of the bills that we plan
to hear today you have to submit a pink
card
so that we will be able to identify you
our clerk representative platt is in
mexico
so he will not be
he will not be here to uh to take notes
this morning
and
if he arrives i plan to ask
representative white to
handle those duties
and
in just a moment i'm going to recognize
representative notter but first
i want to read a
thank you note
that was left here for us
uh at some point possibly last week it
says dear committee and committed
committee chair
thank you tremendously for allowing us
to use this chamber for mock legislature
every member of our committee feels
it deep within themselves to send our
appreciation in writing kindly
chance dawn chair of senate ag
slash
four slash rec slash ed sledge slash hhs
for the ymc youth legislature of new
hampshire
it was very nice of them to
send us that thank you card even though
i don't recall giving them permission
but i don't really need to give them
permission to use this room so
representative notter has an
announcement
there's some muffins in the back not a
lot but if you missed breakfast go help
yourself
okay with that muffin announcement we
shall begin
i'll open a public hearing on senate
bill 268 fn relative to the approval of
power purchase agreements for offshore
wind energy resources from the gulf of
maine and i'll introduce the bill's
prime sponsor senator david waters good
morning senator
thank you very much mr chairman members
of the committee senator david waters
district four introducing
senate bill
268.
this bill um
provides for a mechanism for new
hampshire to protect its interests
when we're considering offshore wind
development in the gulf of maine
i'm sure as all you know governor sununu
uh has expressed great leadership on the
offshore wind industry
development uh he called for the
formation of the gulf of maine task
force um i don't know almost four years
three years ago now yeah
to the bureau of ocean energy management
and in response to that call
the bureau set up the gulf of maine task
force with maine new hampshire
and massachusetts
i know you mr chairman and other members
of this committee are on that uh task
force and that we had its first meeting
in december of 2019 and then covet and
other
uh issues delayed um its act activities
but it will be having its next meeting
on may 19th and uh so this is a
particularly
timely legislation to make sure new
hampshire
uh appropriately takes actions that it
can take to protect our interests in the
development of
gulf of maine
offshore wind and there has been
acceleration in development of the
industry up and down the east coast and
so they're beginning to take shape of a
schedule that we might see
lease areas identified in 2024
and
there already has been area identified
by the state of maine and it's
unsolicited and separate proposal for an
offshore wind research site which could
also impact our fishermen and
environmental
interests so there's a lot going on and
so um
it seemed that we needed to take some
some actions and we really need to
consider the energy economic and
environmental concerns that will come
with offshore wind and what kind of
regulatory authority we want to have
over those issues and then also over
how
these contracts come in and the criteria
by which they are judged by the puc so
we are protecting our new hampshire
interests um and i will say that you
know governor sununu while expressing
his support for
offshore wind development has always
made it uh absolutely clear that he
wants to make sure particularly that our
fisheries but also other environmental
issues and also issues of transit for
getting in and out of our our ports
are
protected and this is appropriate what
for us to do
now the heart of this bill gets at the
fact that
we have authority for regulation
over state waters out to three miles but
then the federal zone
begins
but under a process called consistency
states can declare
an economic and environmental interest
in federal waters out to 200 miles and
then assert its regulatory authority
over those waters
that's why
you'll see the reference to federal
statutes
15 cfr 930 53 and 15 cfr
923 84. and i think we're going to hear
from later testimony these are very
specific criteria by which you can do
this
and what impacts that you can have in
that process but it does give the state
really an extraordinary power to make
sure that its interests are protected
even out into
into federal waters
and um so this bill results from a lot
of discussions with assistant
commissioner sanborn who's really taken
the lead on an offshore win for
for the governor and uh has been working
tirelessly to make sure that the
fisheries and other
environmental interests are protected as
we move forward uh potentially on
offshore
wind so um we met with um
sheree patterson and uh of of um
of the um fish and game eric chapman of
um the sea grant program and other folks
in
des of course and uh in the department
of energy to see what what kind of bill
could we develop that would see to these
interests and this is the approach that
we came up
up with um first so the pieces of the
bill
that you will see here first that we
created an existing um
coastal fund and coastal program in
statute and it seemed this is the
appropriate place to exercise that
authority um we have a coastal fund and
if there are
funds for mitigation and for
environmental concerns that come from
the industry or from the federal
government we need a place to put those
and so therefore we also need a an
advisory group which decides how those
funds should be used to help mitigate
impacts and help our fisheries and so
forth so that's what you see in the
first part of um of the of the bill on
page
one
and then secondly uh gets into this part
about the declaring consistency so
starting at the bottom of page one line
um the coastal zone management
notes the geographic location
description the gld which is the term
that is used in declaring consistency
and so the top of page two
it says that we will use the power that
we do have to declare consistency
related to the development of offshore
wind energy in the gulf
of of maine
um and so how we're going to determine
what our interests are so that's what
you see on page two
this list of uh questions that is
conditioned
in part by what we're allowed to do
under consistency and also attempts to
identify those particular areas that we
need to look at in terms of fish fish
marine mammals reptiles birds habitats
and landmarks
what where they are what our specific
interests are
what are the activities that we have
that overlap with potential activities
of offshore
uh when what those impacts um
uh will be and uh why
um
we may need some mitigation
there and what again the data analysis
is going to be need needed to track
fisheries and other
effects out out there
so that's the body that will be
empowered to do
this work and then some definition of
mitigation and impacted communities and
and so on towards the end there
so just to say in conclusion um you know
why we need to do this well
we will then have this tool these tools
in our tool chest we will know what the
situation is and then the tie-in
uh to the puc and with the previous bill
that you have heard senate bill 440.
that new hampshire and the legislature i
think needs to be have the capacity here
to determine okay if this is what we say
we want for new hampshire interests then
the puc in reviewing contracts for
offshore wind
needs to respect these criteria
we do this in other areas and
it's an essential tie-in i think between
senate bill 268 and senate bill 240
because between those two
um with the department of energy and 440
developing criteria
and then the consistency criteria
environmental control in this bill that
they come together to represent our
positions and i think frankly the
governor's positions on offshore wind
as well so um with that mr chairman we
got to take any questions that the
committee may have
thank you
senator for introducing this bill i'm
sure representative harrington has a
question or two
thank you mr chairman and thank you
senator for taking my uh question
uh to me the the intent of the the big
part of this bill is in their page one
lines three through six
and it says prior to approving purchase
power agreements for offshore energy and
wind now as you're well aware where new
england is now uh merchant uh
power producers in that the public
utilities commission doesn't say go
build a plant and we'll make sure you
get your money uh someone goes builds a
plant and they try to sell it to the
utilities
how would this change that
and
why is it necessary uh if people are
willing to spend their own money to
build solar wind natural gas plants why
do we need special provisions for
offshore wind if it's a good deal then
people will invest their money
and they won't have to be forced to do
it
well thank you representative for your
question
over here okay peter you got a big head
yeah i see yeah but um
i'm sorry
uh but but thanks for the question and
um
let me know that of course you're right
that developers develop and they try to
find
contract for power to be sold from the
power power source that they've
developed
but we already provide direction to the
poc
for
for these for contracts
um you know we do that and so what's
different here
is because this is offshore wind energy
and there are new issues around it
that are environmental in a different
way
and in particular in this case you know
somebody who's going to build a you know
a new gas-fired plant or you know
something on land we have all that
regulation right
um but if it's out
well these are going to be what 30 40 50
miles out maybe 100 miles out when you
think about the
research
array that um you know in terms of
not out from the shore necessarily but
from new hampshire
uh that the research array is
down east of ways but we have people
will fish out there so why this is
needed then is to say okay we have these
interests in these areas
that
can only be regulated under
this consistency provision
and if we define those interests then we
want to make sure that the puc
takes consideration of them when it
proves this kind of contract so it's
representative it's kind of it is kind
of business as usual
but with this
provision now for something that's
different because we can do consistency
follow-up yeah just so okay that's
that's very helpful thank you very much
so what you're basically saying then if
i've got it correct
is that
um the it's business as usual as far as
the utility would come to the puc and
say here's a purchase power agreement
that we've signed you have to look at it
to make sure it's in the best interest
of the ratepayers of new hampshire
but there's certain provisions that are
different because it's offshore wind
which is kind of obviously a new
phenomenon but you're not
the bill doesn't intent like in
massachusetts where the utilities were
basically told in other states as well
you must buy the output of these there's
there's no must buy in this
no thanks for your question no there's
no there's no this is not a procurement
mandate
thank you very much and i'll just add as
as well that um you know it's also
important here too that
we r we recognize and we do this in
other places as well that lines five and
six where you know there are some
studies that have to be done and uh the
poc often asks for you know in terms of
reviewing contracts asked for certain
information and studies and this says
yeah you know the utilities ought to in
in their contracts bear the costs that
might fall in the state of new hampshire
um to do this kind of regulatory
activity so
thank you representative callie pitts is
recognized for a question
i'm hiding
um thank you senator waters uh two
two points that i i didn't understand is
why do we need a special board
to collect
monies or grants when monies and grants
already come in
and the other is to
with fisheries i would think that 200
miles out
and i have fishermen in my family the
federal government
uh
regulates fisheries and fishermen
pretty strictly so they're looking at
now at the same types of what impact is
this going to have on
fishing and quotas and so do we really
need to re-regulate that or put that
in statute at this time
for your questions um representative um
first place is we have
the um
coastal fund
but the question is if there are
substantial funds coming in
to that fund from offshore wind
for mitigation or for other purposes
then
how do we make sure that voices that
need to be heard about how to allocate
that funding are heard
and that's that's why the list
is is here and it's pretty extensive
because it's complicated out there it's
not just a fisherman it's marine transit
it it it might also be there's a lot of
cabling out there already um so you know
where where is uh the power going to be
on short and what regulation do we have
over that as it might impact um marine
transit lanes or
fisheries or other things as well
and then secondly you know i am on the
atlantic coast marines fisheries
commission which uh manages fisheries
from
maine to florida i'm one of the i'm i'm
your legislative commissioner on that
that body and then we have the other
management
uh groups out there and yes they do a
lot to regulate fisheries and stocks
but this is this is different because
i'm not interested in putting a lot of
new regulations on fishermen right
that's what that this is about this is
about making sure that the fishing
bottom
is identified and protected to the
extent that we can so their economic
livelihood
is not unduly impacted and that that is
just crucial we need that for consistent
that's why we do consistency because
otherwise
we have no guarantee that the
federal government is going to
necessarily protect
our fishermen and the way we want them
protected and i think you're going to
hear from assistant commissioner sanborn
as well that you know under the bone
process he has been working you know
tirelessly with other states
to um do stakeholder impact studies
which is an extensive process but there
again
you know we we need a tool that says
we have authority to protect new
hampshire interests so this is a i think
i've answered both questions
you need to follow
up representative samson is recognized
for a question
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
waters uh just a clarification in in the
in this bill
talk about a
coastal program
and there's talk about an agency
advisory board
can you
tell me a little bit about what the
differences are and what they do
well we have the coastal program that's
only in existence yeah which you which
maybe you'll hear about from concepts
when we and we the coastal program has
been a federal entity which has been set
up for years to help
coastal communities deal with federal
regulation and to support the
sustainability of their
you know their fisheries theirs their
uses of the shoreline
water waste treatment all those kinds of
things it's it's me it gets funding from
the feds and uh helps communities out
with with what they have to do so what
this is doing is saying yes we have that
in statute now that's what
we did i guess two years ago now
but this says okay within that program
for this particular purpose we have this
board set up
for the funds that may come in about
offshore win to make to to offer advice
for that fund how to
how to deal with the money
okay thank you
representative mcgee is recognized for a
question thank you mr chairman and thank
you senator for taking my question
um i you know
we often use the term enabling
legislation and from the description
that you've given it seems to me as
though we're taking what we know at this
point and putting it into this
legislation in order to
affirm how we're moving forward
um
by giving definition to the things that
are lacking right now in the statute
would that be an accurate
characterization of what this bill is
trying to do thank you representative
but and i think important to notice here
is is that this issue of consistency
is it is ex it really provides an
extraordinary opportunity for us to
protect our
our interests so
um and i it's not technically enabling
because there is
you know the the coastal program
and the des are able
under the federal statute the state can
declare consistency okay
but how it is done when it is done
and what the criteria are
is what this becomes powerful it is very
timely as well as you might imagine our
our fishermen in the fishing communities
up and down the coast are shall i say
just really freaked you know
because they're they're beleaguered in a
lot of ways for all kinds of reasons and
now here comes offshore wind potentially
so this is important right now before
this leasing process begins to say we've
got your back okay
thank
you
additional questions for the senator
representative pleasure
thank you chief
thank you senator waters uh
in committee was there any
um discussion on kinetic wave energy for
um
producing power
this is just when it seemed like it was
just for wind thank you
thank you for your
question this is just about wind because
the context right now is the bureau of
ocean energy management governor soon
who called for the task force we've got
the task force it's meeting and that's
the body that's going to establish for
this kind of wind energy i think the the
kinetico wave is it boy that's
interesting technology there's some
experimentation being done now off of
the coast of scotland with it and uh
and other places as well so um but that
too when when the time comes that will
be have to have to be regulated but this
bill actually with consistency
would also let us i think give us a leg
up on if that comes forward too
uh representative partial has a question
thank you chair for taking my question
with consistency
would could you see a potential
situation down the line
where the state will be in a situation
of defending
um states rights to our citizens over
federal regulations such as migratory
bird patterns or
exhausting the fisheries could you see
us being at odds with the federal
government were we to claim consistency
out between miles
well thanks for the question and i think
some others may be able to address that
more more particularly but you know i
mean this is one of the advantages of
this kind of bill and having consistency
that you you can get into court if you
have to
rather than just the hammer coming down
and save my way of the highway
and so i think that you know that i mean
that's always a negotiation isn't it
between states and federal regulation
right
so i i would hope that the federal
government will understand the infinite
wisdom of new hampshire on all things
thank you okay follow-up by the same
token i would hope that new hampshire
will understand there are issues that
sometimes
are better handled on the federal level
um such as some environmental concerns
yeah so i think that i could see it
going both ways thank you representative
and i think that that's why
you know that language on page two is is
really um geared to what
you know i mean the the consistency
under the federal statute wants to make
sure this is a process that
is reasonable and not likely to you know
lead to
controversy and so on and that's why
those categories are important because
it it's kind of these are the guardrails
these are the kinds of things you can do
um
thank you
i have a question
on lines
eight through eleven
yep the bill talks about
funds being deposited in a fund
established under paragraph one
what
piece of
legislation establishes that fund
because i looked in rsa
362h2 didn't find it there
is it under rsa 485 somewhere yeah yeah
no it is okay yeah and that was part of
the
coastal program bill that we passed two
years ago
so the second question is on lines 23
through 25
that authorizes the
department of environmental services to
deduct administrative charges from that
fund
to ensure proper oversight and
administration
what is your assessment of
how much money is involved would be
involved in in that fund
i don't know
um
you know we don't i mean i may be
corrected later on but i
some of the see the funding that has
been
accrued from the offshore wind industry
by states like massachusetts or
connecticut or
now new jersey rhode island and
then so for new york
um have been under
um state procurement mandates
and they've gotten tens and tens of
millions of dollars now we're not doing
that
but i would think that
you know you would have to make a
reasonable argument as to okay here's
the impact
and this is what we need is it going to
be some boat buyback is it going to be
um
you know what kind of economic aid i
mean i i i is it going to be supporting
other kinds of fishery programs or
transitioning other kinds of fisheries
beats me so um
i think it could be i think it could be
relatively substantial
and the 10 percent here is a kind of
boilerplate that recognizing that you
know the state should the state be
paying to bring on another employee or
should the industry because you know
we're dealing with their
with them and that's why
we came here
with this figure i would imagine that if
it became clear later on
that the um
you know the
the amount of money that might be
involved the legislature could always
make adjustments to that
great thank you representative callie
pitts has another question yeah i do i i
thank you consistency please correct me
because i'm trying to wrap my head
around it
um will we be declaring
jurisdiction of all matters to the 200
mile limit and that would include
anything that the federal government
might want to do
so i'm thinking in the future not only
by with wind
and has any state
other than new hampshire
use this constit consistency method
and does that have to be granted or we
just take it
well thanks for your question um
it's very defined and limited
over what authority is granted under
consistency to the issues that you see
basically enumerated it's about
fisheries and marine resources
that we want to say that what happens in
federal water is consistent with state
authority over those those kinds of
matters
and answer to your so it's not like
every single thing out there i mean
homeland security coast guard you know
et cetera et cetera et cetera have
jurisdiction over a lot of these things
secondly um
rhode island
uh has been in this game early
and it's had a major impact on what kind
of development could take place
in vineyard wind and elsewhere down
there
um i'm not sure what the current count
is but i suspect that all the states one
way or another
uh will be undertaking this
can i follow
okay i have okay all the other states
has any other state officially
claimed
this consistency privilege and i think
rhode island rhode island yeah that's
right okay and there may be more about i
but i know about rhode island okay and
where i was going was drilling because
that would have impact on
other things so that that was just one
of the s the sidebars
but thank you rhode island has declared
it
and did they have to be granted it or
would they just say it
well you'll hear from des about this
process okay we do have the authority
but what's important if you're going to
assert the authority is to do it
right and that's what this bill
does thank you
representative harrington has another
question thank you mr chairman i think
you've taken my question senator is it
just
a statement saying if i'm right or wrong
on this is the consistency basically
gives us a seat at the table is that the
best way to describe it
thanks for the question i think it does
a lot more than that yeah okay because
we we we come to the table with some
power okay great follow-up
uh in
page one paragraph line eight it says
all money is collected by the state to
mitigate and it goes on from there
collected under who are they collecting
from and under what vehicle are we
collecting it
well
um that
it could be
entirely from the industry
excuse me when you say industry you mean
offshore yeah the developers
it also could be
federal funding there has been a lot of
talk you may hear more from
assistant commissioner sanborn about
appropriations
coming from the federal government to
help fisheries which has been done in
other circumstances previously
you may remember the boat buyback from
what 10 years ago now
um so that would be another potential
source as well so the it hasn't been
defined yet but what you're saying if
and when these monies become available
this is what we do yeah
thank you
okay great senator thank you very much
for introducing this bill
and we have a few more questions i'm
sure but we'll get those answered by our
next testifier and i'll be back for 269
in a few minutes okay great thank you
thank you for being here
so with that we'll call now call on the
assistant commissioner of the department
of environmental services mark sanborn
to give us his perspective on this
legislation good morning commissioner
good morning chairman uh for the record
mark sanborn assistant commissioner des
i know you guys have a lot of bills
today so i'll
hone in for my testimony on a couple of
the issues that have been brought up and
in your conversation with senator waters
first and foremost i would suggest that
whether you think of wind in the gulf of
maine is a great idea you're agnostic or
you think it's a terrible idea i would
still suggest that supporting this bill
is in the best interest of the state
because i would call this bill a bill
that protects us more than that this is
legislation that protects us
um a couple specific things
the key with why senator waters bill is
so important is
you can only claim federal consistency
if you are relying on existing state law
state statute so that is why passing
this is so critical
yes we regulate out to three miles
but the concept of federal consistency
is because
um impacts for commercial interests
either be economic or environmental
safety etc extend well beyond those
three miles the concept of federal
consistency is
if there is going to be an impact in
federal waters to your states on any of
those fronts
you do have the right to claim federal
consistency
you can't claim federal consistency on
anything you don't have a state statute
defining that so we couldn't right now
nothing exists in state statute about
protecting commercial interest of
commercial fishermen
if you put something like offshore or
offshore wind a farm
so because we don't have that in state
statute we couldn't
apply for federal consistency with the
federal government
right now so that's why this is so
important because
there could be gulf of there could be
offshore wind in the gulf of maine the
federal government and one of the other
gulf of maine states could move forward
whether we like it or not
so this allows us to
i do like your term
representative harrington have a seat at
the table
if offshore wind is moved forward with
and we're not a part of it
we could also be a part of the
conversation
massachusetts could decide to move
forward with procurement want our
support for that procurement and the
lease through boem and we could have an
agreement with massachusetts that our
commercial fishermen would be part of
any mitigation they work out with the
developer um that's
there have been many models even though
it's a
it's been a
we have a short history here in new in
the united states on offshore wind there
are some examples
and
um there are many examples where the
state procuring it um the energy is
going to a different uh it is being
transmitted to a different state
there's already a number of models that
are being worked out there so this
allows us under
any case where offshore wind is moved
forward with in the gulf of maine
whether we're part of the procurement or
not whether we're part of the leasing
agreement or not to be able to play and
you actually apply for federal
consistency with noaa not boehm noah is
the federal agency that
regulates federal consistency to say
there's a safety economic
um
any sort of impact
in with something happening in federal
waters
the fund's been brought up a number of
times the model for what's in this
legislation is rhode island rhode island
is the only state right now that has in
the united states that has an active
wind farm it's very small by these
scales but it is active
they when the developer
came in and and had an agreement this
was the way they handled the mitigation
for their commercial fishermen they set
up a fund the developer put the funds in
that fund and then it was regulated
based on with the state
so
um
to the one of the questions yes we have
ways of receiving grants and loans but
this would be a mechanism to
um
handle
monies from private companies and
developers that would be set up
and right now because the federal
government actually doesn't regulate
commercial
mitigation they're working on guidance
but there are no federal statutes or
regs on this it is done in the
negotiations for every individual
wind farm development
the last
item i want to touch directly and then
i'll happy to answer a question is um
as i mentioned earlier the key to this
legislation is
it puts in state statute the items that
if impacted in federal waters we would
want a voice in whether we're part of
the procurement or not
and that is the key to this legislation
in my opinion that's what we based it on
all the issues that the senator waters
included in the draft were based on all
of the stakeholder issues that have been
brought up to us in the conversation
asking our new hampshire stakeholders
asking us
to protect their interests
regardless of how the conversation moves
forward with that i'll answer questions
thank you commissioner do we have
questions for the commissioner
representative callie pitts
i would point out that
i'm not on the bill so i can ask
questions the the question that i would
ask is will this
as i envision an offshore wind
farm
would this also
give us greater control over
interconnection points so where this
um where out the cables are strung and
where this particular
type of energy would come into
the state
well
yes it would would it give us additional
control
i i want to be careful
about usually the term control
it would give us a seat at the table
where those conversations are happening
and allow us to at least express
how
any of the issues again
economic energy transmission
it would let us be at the table to
discuss how that would impact new
hampshire
and put forward our voice if there was a
negative impact to us on any of those
fronts
representative harrington has a question
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh this is a little
bit outside of the scope but i figure
while i'll get you here i might as well
ask you sure um
with this with reference to what the
previous speaker uh questioned is
we have we obviously have a site
evaluation committee in new hampshire as
existing statute
how would that impact
offshore wind would that be controlled
if it was only within three miles of the
new hampshire border obviously if the
transmission lands in new hampshire i'm
assuming that would be going to their
guys but what about something that's the
20 or 40 or 50 miles offshore
yeah so that that would any of the
sighting and leasing in federal waters
um this would this would not impact um
that is the purview of bone that's
that that we are in the sighting and
leasing in the bone process for an
offshore wind development we are in what
is their sighting and leasing process so
on the may 19th the next meeting that's
what we're going to be discussing is
what bone does is
they put out
an initial
map
of a body of water
and
then there is a process to work with the
states and the stakeholders
where that border that body of water on
identifying areas
they start with the areas that should
not be considered for what ultimately
will be called an energy area and you
work your way to identifying what will
be called energy areas um and when boehm
holds one of their auctions leasing
options that's what they're leasing is
the the developer um applies for one of
the identifies one or more of the energy
areas they would like to lease and the
amount they're willing to pay for that
lease
and that's the process we're in right
now and right now we are
boom in october of last year put out a
schedule
um for seven bodies of water for
auctions and the gulf of maine is one of
those uh with a timetable of an auction
uh sometime between the second and third
quarter of the calendar year in 2024
is right now when they're projecting um
they would have put out um identified
energy areas and hold an auction for
developers to bid on
follow-up
follow-up yeah uh so it sounds like
anything
where these uh win projects would
probably be built is going to be federal
jurisdiction and they would regulate the
uh setting it but eventually that uh
power has to get to shore yep so when
that transmission line passes within
three miles and hooks up to some place
on new hampshire would the new hampshire
side evaluation committee have
jurisdiction yeah once he gets the
transmission that part of it would of
course sec under current statute would
have a voice in that thank you
okay additional questions representative
lewicky uh thank you mr chairman thank
you for taking my question
um on the environmental impacts i know
that over the past week or so we heard
about a major energy company being fined
millions of dollars for killing golden
eagles and bald eagles
um i assume that we would expect the
same here what other environmental
impacts might there be and how serious
might they be is there any experience
with that yeah it was a great question
so there is experience mainly overseas
not so much here
um but what i will tell you is what
we're doing to address that
um
number one from a process standpoint
and again this is defined by federal new
hampshire doesn't have a voice in this
part of the process
um under federal statute nepa doesn't
happen until after the auction
because that's when there's an actual
project an area a plan identified
developer who will come forward with a
plan and that's when full nipple will
happen what will happen between now
and uh the 24th will be some
environmental assessments um as part of
boehm's process now in addition um and i
think i've mentioned this in front of
the committee a couple of times we have
moved forward
we were able to get some arpa funding
and we out of the state on our own are
doing um an
assessment study that's going to look at
offshore wind in the gulf of maine and
it's both positive and negative impacts
in three buckets energy environmental
economic um and um
and basically look at the potential
positive negative impacts in those three
areas
we are in the process of reviewing the
proposals we've received for the rfp and
should be able to announce an identified
contractor um i hope it'll get through
gnc
by summer and i and i think we'll get
results um starting next summer from
that so we are going to look at
the gulf of maine specifically um
through that and included and that will
be potential both positive and negative
environmental impacts
thank you follow up please yes follow up
uh is there any experience with this
does anybody have any idea whether we're
going to essentially be slaughtering
birds or whether it's just going to be
minimal sure sure yeah no like i said so
um there's a great deal of experience in
europe
we have the experience in rhode island
um and from a study perspective um a
number of states have
moved forward with full environmental
impact as they start their win farm so
so yes there have been wind farms in the
world um and that'll uh
examples i mean obviously we're going to
be looking at gulf of maine but um there
there there is uh some level of evidence
and and materials to look at in terms of
wind farms that have been deployed
throughout the world and the impact it
has had on um
different um habitats environmental um
uh indigenous species etc including
birds
representative partial
thank you chair rose
um hypothetically uh
expanding upon um uh john oh
representative loki's question
hypothetically
um
suppose we have come up with our study
here in the state and we decide that
vertical axis wind generators have less
environmental impact on migratory birds
we asked for that stipulation to be
within
the lease of whatever uh wind farm that
uh is going to be auctioned can we
insert our authority there do you
believe or was that because it's a
federal auction
would our authority be negated
so um
let me answer that question this way
as i mentioned a couple times from this
committee i don't view my job as to
advocate for a policy outcome i view my
job is to gather information
for the policy makers and
residents and constituents and to
deliver it and to
maintain our participation in the
federal and multi-state process so we
have a seat at the table
i can assure you that right now
new hampshire has a fantastic
relationship with boehm and the other
two states involved in gulf of maine
and i work on a weekly basis
make making sure that the perspective
and the priorities of our state
are voiced in all those conversations
um i will say this and you know as you
know i've had
most of my time has been said in the
federal government um this is a very i
have to give mom credit it's a very
collaborative process they want the
voices of the other folks in there
because the truth of the matter
bohm doesn't actually have a lot of
statutory authority they don't have the
ability to enforce mitigation
compensatory mitigation
they don't have specific guidelines on
final development so a lot of this is
done in a collaborative way based on
negotiation between the states bone and
developers
noaa
and then
on a safety level u.s coast guard
defends some of the safety issues
involving our coast and ports
you know not even mentioned yet a big
reason we're at the table is we want if
there is going to be offshore wind we're
investing all this money in the new
hampshire port right now we want some of
that
supply chains operations to go through
our port and not just some of the other
ports in new england so
the answer to your question is we are
maintaining a positive collaborative
nature with all the parties involved so
all of their their know about our
assessment they're very interested in
the findings
we've
suggested through our delegation and our
governor
boehm is doing some research items we'd
like to research so we will be able to
bring the information we gather to the
table
um as long as we have both the authority
that'll be that which will be helped by
this legislation being passed um and by
maintaining our position within the
conversations that are happening
one follow-up quickly thank you very
much for the follow-up so one assuming
that if this is legislation that
positively impacts the entire
negotiating um
collaboration that we're doing uh
are you aware is maine pursuing similar
legislation or massachusetts so um so
one thing about federal consistency um
federal consistency has existed before
offshore wind and like i said it's
actually through noah not bone federal
consistency is something that has
existed for a while in terms of
a state being able to
identify impacts that are happening in
federal waters so the federal
consistency part of that is this is not
new and so
i bet you almost every coastal state has
used federal consistency at one point or
another
just not for offshore wind um
so
uh
but yes but
this legislation allows us to put on
uh on the books and in our statutes how
we would regulate within the three miles
which will then allow us
to
invoke federal consistency if it's done
outside of those three miles and whether
we move forward with it or not and i can
almost guarantee not only will this
project not be within three miles i
can't imagine it's going to be within 20
miles of the coast so this was going to
be in federal waters
but it will still impact our folks and
we need
i would suggest
we it would mean much in our benefit to
have on the books the things that allow
us
to in the federal process say
what you're doing in those federal
waters is going to impact
what are our stakeholders and our
constituents um and we'd like a voice to
make sure that those impacts are
addressed thank you for your excellent
answer okay thank you we're going to
forego questions from uh co-sponsors on
this bill and we thank you uh
commissioner for your testimony sure
that'll give us time to hear uh
testimony from
uh the department of energy and we
welcome once again to the stand uh mr
roberge
it goes on a hearing by hearing basis
given how much time we have so mr
robarge you're on uh thank you mr
chairman members of the committee uh for
the record griffin roberts from the new
hampshire department of energy i'm not
going to take up too much of the
committee's time i think senator waters
and uh
commissioner
uh sanborn spoke to this plenty enough
the department is in support
for many of the reasons as expressed by
the previous speakers
we just view this as
another
tool in the toolbox i guess to make sure
that new hampshire's interests are well
represented when it comes to offshore
wind energy sighting and with that happy
to take any questions
any questions for the representative
from the department of energy
seeing none
well thank you for your uh testimony
this morning and i have no other people
signed up to support the bill so what i
would like to do now
is
have a show of hands
of everyone on the committee who is here
today
about whether you support this bill or
not
so everybody who would support this bill
please raise your hand
okay thank you looks like we have near
unanimous support so i would now ask uh
representative samsuch as the ranking
member how would you feel about going
into exec session on this bill
does anybody have a comment about going
representative callie pitts
i feel that this committee has always uh
announced executive sessions and if it's
a 22nd
executive session that's fine but i feel
it should be announced before
the bill is
i know it says that executive sessions
may be held throughout the
but
this committee has always
and in the past
announced executive sessions
that's a
okay i will just point out that if we do
not execute this bill today we'll have
to exec it on another day and that just
adds to the workload so representative
mick williams do you have a comment
i do um i think that science technology
and energy has been really solid about
letting all of our members know in
advance exactly what our schedule would
be and that's something that i really
really appreciate about this committee
and so out of respect for the members
who couldn't be here today for the
hearing but would definitely be here for
an exec
i think it's fair can we put it on the
docket for tomorrow
certainly
okay if that's the consensus then we'll
wait to do an exact session i was hoping
to uh
in this in the
interest of efficiency to get it out of
the way because i think we're all going
to support it but if the committee wants
to wait we'll wait
more work to do tomorrow
we'll be here later tomorrow so
representative mick williams if you
could give us the blue sheet data on
this bill please
absolutely um the blue house uh house
remote testify sign and had 33 in
support one opposition zero neutral
it'll be open until midnight tonight
thank you
but that will close the public hearing
on house chairman question yes
representative
harrington thank you just for expediency
maybe we can just announce now to say
that
when we say that executive sessions
could be held at any time that's exactly
what we mean because we have a lot of
bills so all members of the committee
should be aware that on any day we could
have an executive session and plan
accordingly
that is true
okay so with that we will we will uh
call the executive session on house bill
268 fn uh as concluded representative
sausage you have a comment uh yes i
would like to make a comment i mean i
agree with the representative harrington
that that's what's in the in the
in the uh verbiage that we have for
these things however i have always
appreciated the fact that uh
our the chair has given us that uh
information when he planned to have
executive sessions and as you know and
reminded everyone uh
if you are not present for an executive
session you might want to get a
substitute so calling executive sessions
spontaneously doesn't let us do that so
i appreciate if that would be followed
in the future
representative murder
yes
you're taking it the wrong way he asked
for a show of hands i'm sure the
chairman never would have called for an
exec session if he knew there was
dissension in the troops he's just
trying to clear up a bill so you're
making you know filling seats on a
unanimous bill would be silly
i agree
representative partial yes thank you
chair i would love to exact this now
i'll be very honest with you i mean
because
it's it's uh it seems like it's really
however
however um i knew there was at least one
person that did not raise their hand
and i'm wondering if we do put it off
for 24 hours if we might be able to get
a unanimous consent on it
which would be twice an advantage
i don't know it could explain it's
possible representative thomas
yes thank you mr chair uh in view of
that last statement perhaps i would
recommend that perhaps later on this
afternoon if there's another low between
uh public hearings that we might again
attempt to do a exec on this bill and at
that time i suppose if if it is
unanimous
i would suggest that we do it then we
have a tremendous workload and uh to uh
representative murderer's point the
speaker has told us in the past if there
is going to be an executive session
coming up and it's unanimous then
don't
use up our resources by having a
substitute come in for just that one
purpose so i would recommend that we
take another look this afternoon another
opportunity and at that time you will
have the lunch period to have your
caucus if you want to to discuss it and
this way we can shore up some of the
easy bills today instead of extending
our day tomorrow
representative nutter
thank you mr chairman and ditto to what
um
representative oh what is his name from
london
the representative from londonderry i
was late i know but still sorry i just
forgot your name for a second it happens
to my children all the time so you're in
good company um i was the representative
who didn't raise their hand but i'm not
going to go against the committee if the
committee wants this bill i'm going to
i'll vote with all of you so it'll be
unanimous
so representative callie pitzer you
still opposed to doing an exec session
later today if we have time
yes i am i thought we were meeting on
the 19th so we have plenty of time to do
this
as far as i can tell
um it has an fn on it
does it have to go to our uh
finance committee
i do not believe so so we have and and i
and i again i was under the impression
we were meeting on the 19th
and if this is going to take 20 minutes
we just took 20 minutes to talk about
doing it so
to execute tomorrow would take
what
five minutes
if it's if it's we've got unanimous
consent and i think that would
that would be
more acceptable to me so i do
okay there's one other issue here that i
want to make sure everybody understands
we have 17 senate bills
there are going to be two house sessions
at which these 17 bills will be
presented on the floor of the house
april 21st
and may 5th
it is my hope that we can bring half of
these bills to the house floor on april
21st
and the other half to the house floor on
may 5th
the alternative would debri be to bring
them all to the house floor on may 5th
is that going to be fair to the other
members of the house to present 17
stne bills on one day
is that going to be fair to the members
of this committee who want to engage in
floor debates
i don't think that's fair i think we
should try to break this up
and get these bills separated
to the house floor on the 21st and the
5th and to do that we've got to exec
them
we can't wait till the 19th because all
bills exec on the 19th will go to the
house floor on may 5th
the only bills that will go to the house
floor on the 21st are bills that we
execute today or tomorrow
so i want to make sure everybody
understands that so that you'll
understand what we're trying to
accomplish as we go forward
representative harrington yeah i would
just say mr chairman i totally agree
with you uh let's face it we bore the
hell out of the house anyways if we give
them 17 bills we'll be lucky if anyone's
still awake when we get to 12 or 13 so i
think definitely want to break them up
and get as many as we can in on the
first session
representative sausage
thank you uh i would just agree with uh
representative kelly pitts i think to if
we executives tomorrow
where a lot of people from our side at
least know that we are having an
executive session it might take as
little as two minutes to do it it's a
quick thing to do it was planned to do
that i don't think there's any real hold
up if we do it tomorrow so i would
support doing it tomorrow
okay so we'll do it tomorrow and i want
to alert everybody to be prepared to
exact eight bills tomorrow
and if we're here till six or seven or
eight o'clock tomorrow night so be it
all right
so
it is now time to
open a public hearing on senate bill
269-fn
establishing a commission to study
energy-saving
weatherization programs
and
senator waters is going to introduce
this bill because the prime sponsor
senator a bard is not with us today
so
senator waters take it away
thank you mr chairman senator david
water district 4 introducing
senate bill 269 because
senator avar could not be here
today
this bill establishes a commission to
study energy saving weatherization
programs in iran if you've looked at the
original bill you see what the original
intent had been
you know fundamentally to try to
expedite
the
provision of a workforce to do this kind
of energy efficiency work to make sure
that we had people who could do the do
the work with less regulation and then
secondly it was uh going to see if we
can't open up
um the possibilities of participation in
this this program uh to larger mill
building conversion propane and gas
folks and
and so on um
the original bill raised some issues
about uh
you know what workers would be unable to
do what under this program and um also
a lot of you know more complicated
issues than have been this anticipated
about what it would mean to expand the
um inclusion of other kinds of of
building energy sources to it so
that's why it seemed like it really
would make some sense to
take a look at this in the commission
and you'll see the issues really uh
listed starting on
line 12 of what came up in the um
hearing you know what policies do we
need to look at
for the reservation of building so we
could include buildings heated with uh
all these all these fuel sources
um
and then within
uh which programs well we know new
hampshire saves we've talked a lot about
that over the last year and those funds
have come in and get administrated by
our
caps
and how what might we
expand the physical participation of
propane and oil users in new hampshire
in the same
way that we now include electric and
national natural gas seem fair i would
think but also i think it seemed
effective if the point here is to help
lower income folks saving energy bills
no matter what they're heating
with and then some particular
questions about what could be covered in
this i think which sea lions 20 to 22 is
kind of
residual from the original 10 of the
bill to look at mill bidding building
conversions and other multi-family uh
structures as well where these these
kinds of things might be part of the
work that
is done
so
then of course you got the commission
members and
so on as as usual after
after that and uh it is going to
get this work done pretty quickly to tee
up potential legislation for next
session so mr chairman that's it in a
nutshell
great thank you for introducing this
bill on the behalf of
senator avard
do we have questions for the senator
representative mirner is recognized
thank you senator for taking the
question um a little
the pre-qualifications you have two
different
like method things under methodology for
qualifications
so we'll be creating a new set of
rules for the
qualification for the for the work for
the contractors
um
well thanks for your question that was
with in the original bill and there are
a lot of questions about that so why
that's why i got amended to be the study
now usda rural development they do the
same type of work too you know people
apply through them and they have a set
of guidelines i don't know
if there's anything that we could use
off of their guidelines or not
good thought and i think that's one of
the
other reasons why i thought
this this group ought to work on these
things because it suddenly became a lot
more complicated to make it streamlined
so everybody's on the same page yeah
yeah
thank you okay representative mick
williams has a question
uh thank you senator for bringing this
bill um
i guess i'm i just had a question about
the
members of the commission
so i'm looking through the list here and
it looks like you've got good
representation from the public
electric and natural gas providers
the house
clean energy new hampshire
i'm not seeing
anyone representing the licensed
building trades specifically engineering
and architecture which are very focused
right now laser focused on updating
energy
and codes related to that i think we
have some synergy here between what the
building code review board has been
doing about amending and updating the
building code when it comes out every
two years
and i'm not seeing an architect or
engineer who could provide that same
level of accountability and interest
between the two groups as a member of
the commission so i guess my question is
would you be open to an amendment that
adds an architect or engineer to the
membership
well that's your question and you know
um surely uh
i understand that the house can do
amendments as well as the senate can and
so if that seems i mean i i i think it's
a good point um i think that there was
some sense that maybe you get that some
of the expertise coming
from home builders
um builders and contractors and building
officials association because they
obviously work with those folks but that
might be helpful but none of them are
licensed is the point so they don't have
to take continuing ed to keep up with
transitions in the code okay thank you i
would
i would encourage the committee to
consider that and i could whip up an
amendment in about an hour with ols if
the committee's open to that
and thank you and i don't i don't think
senator evard would object to that okay
thank you
i'd remind the members that we're here
to ask questions to gain information
representative pimentel
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
waters for taking my question
um
line 17-18 research to explore
expanding the fiscal participation of
propane and oil users in new hampshire
in the same manner as electric and
natural gas
could you explain to me
what
the intent of putting that in is
and what its ramifications might be
thanks your question i'm not sure i'll
be able to give a very thorough one but
i think that senator avartz uh interest
here was to make sure that all fuels are
treated equally if we're trying to
provide this weatherization help
representative mcgee has a question
thank you mr chairman and thank you
senator for bringing the bill and for
taking my question
towards the end on page 2 line 27
perspective repeal it just mentions rsa
p colon 7c
relative to the commission to study
energy saving weatherization programs is
repealed so we're creating a commission
and repealing a commission is that
i'm just if you can clarify
how that helps
thanks for your question that's kind of
boring
it you know it has a certain period of
time to do its work and then it's then
it goes goes bye-bye
so so yes so it's a built-in repeal for
the work of this commission not
something prior that's being removed in
order to make way for the new it refers
back to line 10 first page 12p 7c it's
this one okay now you see it now you
don't yes okay thanks
representative harrington thank you mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question senator is a follow-up to the
previous question on line 17 talking
about participation of propane and oil
uses in new hampshire in the same manner
as electric and natural gas you said all
energy sources are going to be treated
equally so
by that is one to assume that the intent
here is to put on something equivalent
to the system benefit charge i.e attacks
a fee on propane and oil users similar
to what electric and natural gas users
now pay
not at all thanks your question not at
all
the focus here you see the word users
and no new funding existing program
look at these these other uh
other folks that might be included in it
follow up
follow up thank you i'm a little
confused uh
not says participation of propane in oil
users
in the same manner as electric and
natural gas and my unders but we
obviously know that electric and
national gas have what we refer to
generally as the system benefit charge
where all users are paid pay a certain
tax if you will or a fee on their
electric or gas bill that goes to
weatherization programs i'm reading this
and maybe i'm misunderstanding it but it
seems to me is it saying we want to
expand that to now when you buy propane
you buy oil there will be some type of a
fee that will be collected
by the oil company or the propane
company and it'll be given to some state
entity so they can fund weatherization
programs is that correct well thanks for
the question i'm not sure whether there
is there isn't and notice that we're not
putting anything in statute other than
to study that issue
and um
i do think representative if you if you
felt that this might
you know kind of open a door in a
direction you don't want to go you could
clarify
you could you could fiddle with that
language but um it's it's a study it's a
study yeah
to um
expand on that point it does say explore
expanding the fiscal participation
uh of propane and oil users which would
sort of indicate uh as
representative harrington suggests
that an expansion of the system benefits
charge my apologies chairman it's not my
bill and uh i'm not exactly sure what
senator avar meant by that um but no no
it's it's a study
my my question would be
isn't there
every
day i open my mailbox and there's a
flyer in there from somebody who wants
to install new windows at my home
or sell me
other
home weatherization products isn't there
already a robust market
for this
kind of economic activity and and why do
we need to to study it i i'm not quite
sure what the purpose of all this is
well
thanks for your question i mean the two
key things that you bet there's a market
this is about new hampshire saves
and the particular group that it's
served
and what it's trying to look at is okay
can we do something about certification
so that we're not putting so much
so many regulatory hurdles on folks who
want to come in and do this work
and that would probably help us get the
work done and then secondly let's take a
look at the program to see if it might
include things like mill buildings or
multi-family houses and whether those
are appropriate
ways to use the new hampshire saves
funding
additional questions seeing none we
thank you senator oops
you got to raise your hands before when
i say additional questions you got to
raise your hands immediately
representative ploje has a question
thank you mr chair uh
thank you senator waters uh just to
clarify uh this study commission is also
for
uh single-family homes i believe and i
noticed that on um i lost the line
but it also mentioned
on seven
four multi families the duplexes and
quad products there's a line in there
is the question is
is this going to be equal for
single-family homes and
multi-family thank you
thank you i
you know i i would think that the folks
who are on this committee
commission will have a lot of questions
and a lot of things to look at
and that's why
it made sense to bring it forward
uh because there are i mean there have
been audit i mean we focused so much
with
you know with 549 on stabilizing the
program and the funding and and that was
really great work thank you committee um
and i think that it's just that okay
now that we have the program um let's
see how we can make it work the best for
the people
and there are a lot of issues if you
look at the committee report you'll see
that there are quite a few issues that
came up
under the original bill um
senator clegg
former senator clegg and uh others
you know had had some thoughts and
concerns about this and that so it
seemed to make sense to say let's have a
let's take a look at these
uh representative samsic
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
waters
online let's see 26 with regard to the
composition of this commission
um
and i'm saying i'm just asking whether
there's any reason
you would know of any of the sponsors of
this bill
would not want to include a member of
the minority party as well
it says three members appointed by the
speaker
and theoretically it could be a member
of the minority party but in some of the
other bills we've been dealing with
there was specific language that said
uh one member of the minority party
appointed by the early party leader
so is there any reason we couldn't do
that here too
it's a commission
thank you representative do you think
that a senator from the other side of
the wall is going to comment upon house
procedures
thank you for your question
representative partial
thank you chair i'm looking at the
amendment
coming back to it and i'm wondering if
it's
um
i don't know maybe i'm misusing the word
but it seems like a non-german amendment
as it assumes uh if the plan is adopted
and while it seems like a fine amendment
um
it doesn't really seem to relate
directly back to this study as far as i
can tell unless we're assuming that uh
certain things will come up come as a
result of the study
um i'm just
trying to wrap my mind around this a
little bit maybe you could help me out
thank you
thanks because i'm um
it's a bill we passed this bill
so
it is germain unto itself it's asking
for a commission to look at issues that
came up
uh under the original bill
but
representative mann do you have a
question
please turn on your microphone
yeah turns out i can thank you
first of all um
am i mistaken i i i believe there are
seven nominees
that are not nominated by seven members
that are nominated by the governor
and there's a quorum of eight for
meeting
is this a little
lopsided in a sense
um you know there are members that are
have no affiliation
just a member of the public member this
member of that
i'm a little surprised that there's some
so much
power in the hands of the governor on
this commission
well thanks for your question i i mean i
will say that i'm pretty used to when i
put together commissions assuming that
the the governor's
authority and and and the ability of
that office to select members of the
public i really i generally trust and so
okay it seems not out of the ordinary to
me but
thank you follow up follow up
um
i noticed there's no examination uh no
no um
maybe i'm pushing too far
i ask you a question that you can't
answer uh but um
why there wasn't anything in the
commission's
tasks related to examining costs and
benefits
to the economy and to in into households
as well
most at the
total new hampshire economy level
and at the individual homeowner level or
home occupant citizen level on costs and
benefits
thanks for your question and you know i
generally strongly support that kind of
inclusion of language although i will
say here that you know the new hampshire
saves program it is what it is and the
costs and benefits of that are something
have been
deeply discussed shall we say over the
last year or so
and i would imagine that any legislation
proposal that might come out of
this commission
would include such a consideration
but
for these purposes um i mean maybe as i
said if you think that that would be
helpful to have that
in there why not add it let's just
digest it
and um
follow up a second third question okay
go ahead one more um
there was uh quite an uproar when the um
puc canceled the e-irs
and there were companies that were um
there was event evidently some very
competent
energy efficiency companies in the state
that kind of
raised their hand at that time
none of these seem to have been
in the uh
don't be seen none of these seem to be
recognized as potential uh uh members of
the uh
of the commission
and i think that they would provide very
valuable information thanks for your
question and that that's why we have on
page two
five and six
because those folks are the ones who
represent those
folks and i think we're going to hear
from the home builders
who have been the vehicle for the voices
of those
thank you folks thank you
and after you finish speaking don't
forget to turn your microphone off
okay
seeing no additional questions for the
senator we thank you for introducing
this bill senator and we'll call on our
next speaker who will be bob soucy
and mr susie um
represents the new hampshire association
of new hampshire propane gas and oil
dealers
mr susie thank you bob scully
sorry my writing was i was going sorry
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record i'm the
president
of energy marketers association new
hampshire and i also have the pleasure
to represent propane gas association new
england
i come in opposition to
senate bill 269 fn i was unable to
participate with it in the senate
and as i read this bill i don't really
believe there's a need to include the
propane and oil folks that i represent
but just to take you to a couple of
sections on this proposed legislation
that i think
does explain its intent
i'd like to take you to page one
line twelve small a
when it talks about the commission's
duties
it says the commission shall identify
policy and funding opportunities
to support weatherization and then they
list the
the energy sources you're looking at
which includes electricity natural gas
oil and propane
the two groups that i'm here today
and
just to show you this distinction
between the utilities in the private
sector
um
utilities they get their rates they're
guaranteed
the rates get baked into the ratepayers
they pay the bills we're private sectors
that doesn't happen with us
so i'm not sure what the funding intent
is whether it's to
have the consumer pay it which in
today's world with the high prices of
energy to heat your homes right now
would not be a welcome alternative okay
we don't have that luxury
of
just taking that race and passing it on
to the consumer okay the private sector
cannot do that
so
i believe
that when we look at this that's what
the intent is here as part of this study
and then you did discuss line 17
research to explore expanding the fiscal
participation of propane and oil users
so once again i mean users i would
assume would be the homeowners
um
but i'm not sure of that okay
so i have concern there um and our
industry already participates in
programs to help those that are less
fortunate need assistance
through the
granite state saves program we supply
money to go back to the consumers for
for new energy efficient boilers for
tanks through the odd fund if there's
leaks in tanks then they can get up to
2500 dollars for a new tank
okay
now that's not weatherization but it's
support for the homeowners and then our
industry
on the oil side participates with the
laihi program
low-income heating assistance program
for those people that qualify
and
so this last year 2021 to 2022 over 60
million dollars was put aside in that
light light heap funding program for new
hampshire folks that need it
so
we are doing an awful lot um right now
to assist those that need help and i
believe that this study is set up to
look at bringing in the folks at least
that i represent here today and if it
wants to move forward i would ask you
one of two things to either take the oil
and propane people out of this or to not
pass
senate bill 269. thank you mr chairman
thank you do you have any uh written
testimony that you could submit i do not
but i'd be happy to write some up for
the committee mr chairman well we'd
appreciate that i will thank you
uh representative thomas is recognized
for a question
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question uh just for
clarification uh since you brought up uh
the oil and propane industry in relation
to
uh programs that you already
uh have to support low-income families
if this commission uh decides to
attach
extra costs onto the oral and protein
industry like the study says it it is
going to be studying
if that were to happen how would that
affect your programs that you were
already supporting for the low-income
families would would you have to do away
with them or reduce them or
i don't um i'm not sure representative
the lahey program is a federally funded
program that comes to the state so i
don't believe that that program would be
impacted by that um
and the the nora funds which is a
industry check off program where the
money is used to
for research for any energy efficient
burners and furnaces and to also assist
funding that with the homeowners i don't
believe that would be impacted either
okay
thank you
representative kelly pitts is recognized
for a question
this bill confused me a little bit so
i'm hoping i can get clarification
the
oil
and propane users
are currently
or i believe that they are currently
eligible for weatherization programs
under the
by the fact that they use electricity
through the sbc charges collected
through the utilities
am i wrong in that particular
i don't know the answer to your question
sorry
i
i'll ask that later then follow up well
anybody who has an oil
heated house
for instance
they can apply for weather associ
weatherization programs now and if they
qualify become funded is that correct
i'm i'm seeing yes
so
then in what you're saying is that the
only reason to put oil and propane in
there is to perhaps
assess additional funds from these
people
and i would say that i believe so
representative samsuch is recognized
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
scully
um so i don't quite understand your your
opposition to the bill um because in
fact it's just a commission
that should look at these things it's
not a recommendation to increase charges
or store surcharges or anything it's
just a commission to evaluate these
issues
and as representative kelly pitts
mentioned anyone who already uses
natural gas or oil
for heating purposes
is already paying uh
into the the utility program that gives
the weatherization to anybody who does
that so whether you use propane or or
oil
you're getting weatherization already
and this bill does not do anything to
change any of these charges or put a new
surcharge it is true that that that
paragraph that representative sam
you're making a speech sorry and i'd
appreciate it if you'd ask a question
instead so okay so so are you
principally against
a commission to study weatherization or
do you just want to remove the reference
to of for oil and propane out of this
bill i'd be happy if you remove the
reference to oil and propane out of the
bill okay thank you
okay further questions representative
mann has a question
don't forget to turn on your mic for
pete's damn thing um
it occurs to me that
especially oil uh and possibly propane
and most heating systems use electricity
as well you have to you have to spray
the oil into the boiler you have to
start the boiler you have to blow
hot air that's created by the by the
furnace to around the house or circulate
hot water so um
it would be possible to um
finagle this i mean can i could we
possibly get
do you know of any
way that i could get numbers in terms of
the the amount of electricity
used by
propane and oil heating systems
which might solve this problem
i mean i could say in general terms
there's plenty of electricity used but i
uh you know i can ask the question i
mean i'm not sure i mean your if i
understand your question you know how
much electricity is used to push the
propane and oil to heat the home correct
yeah given that given that electricity
uh
representative manner of charge on it
yes
you're basically asking a question that
the commission would study we don't need
to know that information to decide
whether or not we're going to establish
this commission so thank you
respectfully i i'd like to confine our
questions to the bill itself
representative lewicki okay thank you mr
chairman and this may be somewhat
hypothetical but mr scully um if this we
wish to start putting a charge on um oil
and propane dealers might we have a
problem of people pirating the energy in
from out of state we've got the fixed
assets for natural gas but all we need
is a truck to get propane or oil in
uh
i would tell you right now that border
communities use dealers out of state
you know in vermont maine and
massachusetts right now
so i would like to believe that the
industry that i represent is honest
um
and they would
comply with the law but um
i guess anything's possible
representative
all right let's not let our questions
wander into what the commission is going
to be studying itself let's just confine
our questions to whether or not this
commission is needed
representative partial
yes thanks for taking my question i'd
like to ask a question uh really
um if i understand correctly i think
that
what this bill may end up doing is
taking a hard look at
bringing uh
oil and natural gas and propane in line
what we're already doing with the
electric industry perhaps
um in funding such uh situations with
new hampshire saves so to me it seems
like a basic question of fairness
but i would
like to you to parse that out for me if
you would and tell me how
you believe that the oil industry should
be exempted from something we're already
doing for the
electric sp
but we already have an electric bill
well representative we're i believe
we're already doing what you're trying
to discuss here our industry is already
um
doing research itself with a check off
program where they're collecting funds
to create more efficient
furnaces and burners so when they
install them in the homes in the state
of new hampshire
and helping fund that new equipment okay
that goes into the users homes because
it's expensive
help to offset the cost for the people
to
improve their energy efficiency in their
homes so we're already doing that and
then we're doing that also
through the odd fund which i think this
committee might be familiar with the oil
disbursement um
program that the state has through des
where
we are using those funds to help
consumers when they need to replace
tanks
so that exists today and that's existed
for probably over 25 years that program
um so we are already i'm being fair um
our industry is already participating in
what you're trying to look at right here
we have two more people who would like
to testify on this bill and i would like
to hear from them both
so
i'd like to move on representative
pementel do you have a question about
the bill itself
thank you mr chairman yes this is about
um
and
the bill itself is a bill to ask a bunch
of questions
essentially
and would you agree with me
that the best way to find an answer is
to ask a question
well representative yes but i believe
the premise of the bill as i read it is
also to expand to those people to put
money in a pot that's the way i look at
what you're trying to discuss
okay mr scully we thank you very much
thank you mr chairman your testimony for
coming forward today
and our next speaker on this issue will
be
an old friend of ours matt mayberry
who's here to represent the new
hampshire home builders association
good day to you mr mayberry and welcome
to sd e good to see you sir good morning
chairman
good morning members
first thank you so much for helping with
the reverse that bad decision with the
puc and chairman thank you so much for
your leadership on that thank you
um
took lots of notes so i'll try to
address some of your concerns as we go
through this
this is a commission to have a
conversation
to have a study
because while electricity is used
to
you know administer oil and propane
through
the original new hampshire
new hampshire saves program was designed
for those homes that heat by electric
they get their heating source from
electric
that's how new hampshire saves was
originally designed
currently right now in new hampshire 10
percent of homes
are heated by electric
so we're having a conversation that
excludes 90 percent
of homes in the state of new hampshire
we like to do is we like to have a
conversation
about our friends
oil propane natural gas electric get all
the stakeholders together
there's 14 members on there of the 14
members three are appointed by the
governor
the rest
come from
your constituents
it's me it's bob scully it's others in
the industry
is to have a discussion because luckily
i'm not a policy
decider you folks are
what's wrong with having a conversation
to talk about an issue to completion
that we haven't had a real conversation
about in years
you folks are the policymakers
i can tell you my new favorite color is
green the new color of the sky
if you folks say no that doesn't happen
i think the public
our constituents this helps the very
lowest of income
of your constituents
because right now for instance under the
current program
you can't replace a window
because they say the payback isn't fast
enough
this commission one things they would
look at
would be
do we change the rate of return on the
windows
because common sense has always said to
me if you have a big gaping hole in your
wall
that's probably the big sieve of your
energy
let's have a conversation about it
we haven't in years
that
there doesn't need this there does need
to be some realignment with the usda
programs and the state programs
because when we did this bill originally
in full disclosure
when i helped draft it
we were in
conflict with federal regulations
and the department of energy said
please don't do that you're going to
hurt our federal program
this will begin to helpfully if you
folks say yes we like these ideas and
again it'll be a menu
you folks pick and choose what you like
and don't like
it'll get us more in line
with the usda
we have no problem with any of the you
know having licensed professionals there
architects engineers
we want all the stakeholders at the
table
we can't have enough opinions because we
all bring life experience from different
perspectives
and so we'll gladly take that
the
i took a lot of notes as you saw i'm
sorry
when you talk about the fiscal
participation
what we're asking this commission to do
is start with a whiteboard a clean
whiteboard
put everything on the table
have the conversation because again
we only would make recommendations
chairman you and the committee
you pass the policies
then it goes to our friends in the
senate
then it goes to the governor
if we don't have a conversation what do
we know we're missing
you know i'll keep it brief because you
know it's been you know a long morning
for you folks already but happy to ask
answer any questions help where i can
give a different perspective
but we just want all the stakeholders at
the table
equal footing equal voice
thank you mr mayberry thank you mr
representative
samsic has a question
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
mayberry for coming and explaining this
to us
um can you explain to me again the the
conflicts with the federal rules that
you said you bumped into originally and
how they were resolved
yes
i'm looking at middle space i'm trying
to think back to that conversation i
think had to do with the administration
or the eligibility
of
of the federal energy savings and
weatherization dollars
back who could use them different income
um
different income criteria
um what i can do representatives i can
get you
i'll look back at my other notes i can
follow back with you this afternoon via
email and tell you where that those
differences were exactly i'm sorry i
don't have a complete answer but i will
get a complete answer
okay uh next question representative
thomas
thank you mr chairman uh thank you mr
mayberry for taking my question
um i just have a
question we
you talked about having conversations
right now i believe the legislature
house between house and senate we have
at least a house anyway we have over 400
conversations going on with 400
commissions and committees
um some have been around forever and
but so my question is
is it possible that we could fold in the
requirements of this commission
into an existing
commission or committee that we already
have established
instead of forming another one to make
it 401
commissions uh
do you think that would you do you think
that this is a a real question do you
think that could be effective absolutely
absolutely we want to have that
conversation i have no problem
consolidating it into one
and having a larger conversation we just
want to participate in it representative
we think it's overdue we all know the
cost of heating our homes and it
strongly affects those on the lowest
income who can't come and spend time
with you today
so we're we're trying to help those
folks up but yes sir we'll gladly
consolidate
thank you
representative pimentel has a question
thank you mr chairman uh thank you mr
mayberry um
on that same line of questioning this
bill has a effective date
would it make sense to put a sunset date
on it it does
it it does it has a date of
it already has it
it
yes the line about uh the committee
being repealed is the sunset date
pardon
the line about the committee being
repealed
is the sunset
provision
yep and then it it ends uh december 16
2022 so it does have a
we're in we're out this is not going to
drag on forever
representative mick williams has a
question
thank you so much mr mayberry for coming
and giving us your testimony today i
just want to get a little bit more into
the specifics
to representative thomas question about
combining with other potential
commissions or study committees i know
we have a lot of work that's being done
by members of the house and senate with
the community to try to find solutions
to many pressing questions
right now i'm seeing a lot of good work
coming out of the building code review
board
is that a potential home for some of
these issues or do you think that we
really do need to have a formal
commission in order to address it
i'm just thinking it through i apologize
i think with the building
code review board
on the
there's a home for vote for both
but my party
my initial thought is that we're looking
at
existing homes right now
where a building code review board would
deal with those homes moving forward
and to certain you know standards at
that point in time but where a vast
majority of our homes are existing
the building code review wouldn't
necessarily pick up those folks
follow up so the building code review
board also covers the international
existing building code so there is an
existing component that our
authorities having jurisdiction within
the towns
look at for existing homes but we don't
necessarily have a piece to feed back
the feedback that we're hearing when
someone does a renovation of a three
family in nashua and they discover that
the insulation is terrible and they
should probably bring it up to code but
it doesn't trigger the dollar signs
questions please
low income
so i'm looking for a way to create a
feedback mechanism and your
recommendation for how that feedback
mechanism could be implemented as part
of this commission either under the bcrb
or not and that's what i want to hear
from you sure i think on page two line
six when it talks about a member of the
new hampshire building officials
association would be there to have that
voice going forward
because if you're going to replace
windows or install more insulation or
change out a water heater that wouldn't
fall either under the
bcrb or the icc
but the building officials would have
that
that voice at that commission to bring
the afford
those comments
so to clarify it sounds like you would
recommend a commission
i recommend passage of this
um because on there there is a member
again
you know
we have no problem adding more voices
but we did bring in the building
officials association that enforces that
code
they would have a c at that table of 14.
mr mayberry thank you very much for your
testimony chairman thank you so much
have a nice day thank you
we have one last person who would like
to testify on this bill
and that is matt menning who represents
elm grove companies
mr manning welcome thank you mr chairman
elm grove companies is a
developer
renovator operator multi-family
apartment so
my experience in this world comes from
a user of the new hampshire saves
program many times over
we've renovated hundreds of
single-family homes
maybe
over a thousand apartments
and i think that our experience in that
world of renovating existing housing
stock rather than
primarily building new homes
has shown us the pervasiveness of
poor energy management in our structures
in the state
um
if you are a low-income homeowner or
a low-income renter an apartment
the things that are in your face are
roof leaks plumbing issues heating
equipment
a homeowner that has to replace the roof
for ten thousand dollars and doesn't
have even a thousand in the bank
they have to deal with that problem the
fact that their
utility bill is two or three x what it
should be if it was properly insulated
it just can't register they can't spend
another ten or fifteen thousand dollars
when um
improving the weatherization of their
home so
i think
mar our interest in this is to look at
the program as a whole
funding levels where does it come from
but also how the program is administered
because
it's
relatively opaque even to a company that
specializes in renovation
we've been surprised as the whole um puc
discussion has evolved over the last few
months and we've learned more
some of these
allocations of funds and what's eligible
and what's not and whether you're on the
electric utility or natural gas utility
or you're heated by propane or oil or
something else
there's different pathways you can go
down it can get kind of confusing so
it's not just about funding but it's
also about how do we spend the dollars
we have in the most efficient way and
how do we help people
understand
those pathways and make them easier to
go down
it i don't i don't know the stats on it
i'm not an expert but
the number of homes that have no
insulation in the state is significant
because we've been into hundreds of them
the first duplex i bought in nashua he
brought up a three family in nashua
lived there for a few years uh noticed
the gas bills really high my my tenant
next door same thing
put a drill under the wall there was
nothing it was just air straight through
to the siding so
that was a
12 000 job that one did qualify for
the new hampshire saves program which i
think cut that cost by about 40 percent
and
i think where we want to see this
commission look at is how do we how do
we help more people
make that kind of improvement and make
it in a way that's financially feasible
for them
the other thing i'd say that
makes this discussion particularly
pertinent is the world economy that warn
ukraine the energy prices that have
resulted from
that instability
we don't have any control over that in
the state of new hampshire right but we
do have control over what we invest in
our energy usage
so
i think
now more than ever when energy prices
are high is when we should be really
looking hard at making this program as
efficient and effective as possible
so i'll take any questions you may have
thank you okay thank you for your
testimony uh representative mcgee has a
question thank you mr chairman and thank
you mr manning for taking my question
um i know i actually had this question
for a couple of speakers now and i think
maybe you could speak to it as well
when mr scully spoke he talked about
several federal programs that um
oil and propane
companies
leverage to assist their customers and
it sounded like most of them were
focused more on the equipment upgrades
that you were talking about right so if
you can get a more efficient boiler
you know or
make some kind of capital investments
you wouldn't otherwise be able to afford
as a low income person
you would use nora or some of the other
programs he mentioned but that's very
distinct from the weatherization savings
right so
um
i think that's the question that i have
i mean i look at this bill and i say
it's looking really at
energy saving weatherization
[Music]
it says energy saving weatherization
program so it i think
to me the bill looks like a study
program specifically around
weatherization savings so what is that
and not and not
not the other programs that he was
saying well we do these so you know you
don't need this you don't need to look
at this
um i think
the programs that he says
are federally funded to help people with
their oil burners and that sort of thing
that's not the same thing as this study
committee
is that your understanding as well
yes i
it's all it to make a home energy
efficient it's all the above right to go
from a 50 efficiency boiler to a 96
efficiency boiler
that makes a huge difference but to
lose at a rate of you know
have the actual envelope that's heating
be a sieve right you could have the most
efficient boiler in the world but you're
still going to spend
a lot of money heating the outdoors
um
so
that's that's one of the things that i
would look at if i were to be on this
commission which i'd like to be and
volunteer for but
how do you pull these programs together
in a way that makes it
the full picture for a homeowner or for
a renter yeah
because it's not just the equipment it
is the envelope
so yeah
representative harrington has a question
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
your introduction was a little brief so
could you you
own a business work for a business what
exactly does your business do sure so uh
i'm one of four partners at elm grove
companies we
own
and or manage about 1500 apartments in
the state
we have been in business since 2009
and historically have focused on
renovation and redevelopment
both of single family homes but also
large multi-family
if anyone knows manchester on elm street
there was the
city hall and
ted herbert's music school
the kind of renovations we do we'll
we'll gut a building out we're very
familiar with what it takes to retrofit
uh weatherization spray foam insulation
dense pack
uh weather stripping windows doors you
name it we've been through it
follow-up mr chairman follow up so if uh
if this commission were to identify
funding opportunities and
expand fiscal participation of propane
oil users in the new hampshire in the
same manner as electric and natural gas
there would be more funds available
for you to sell your service to so you
would hence make more money off of this
bill if it was to come if those actual
funding opportunities became real
theoretically yes
i won't say anything to the contrary but
i think most of our buildings are
serviced by natural gas and electric so
how we would
be affected by this could be relatively
minimal but
it's actually been in some of the rural
communities where we don't have that
much activity for our own business where
the funding sources through the electric
utility and there's a few questions
about that
i don't understand the system benefits
charge very well but i i know just
enough that
if you are not on
uh electric heat through the utility or
natural gas heat
even though there is funding available
for a homeowner who lives in northern
new hampshire for instance
it's limited significantly because you
you that structure is not paying into
the
utility that actually heats that home
i believe there is funding i don't know
the exact rules i'm sure someone from
liberty or eversource could speak to
that further
representative samsic has a question
thank you mr chairman uh thank you mr
manning
uh in your experience based on your your
rehab work and and redevelopment
what do what do you see as the the most
uh cost efficient way of reducing energy
use
if you every building is different right
depending on the existing conditions but
generally we have found that stopping
air penetration is the number one thing
air penetration can be through
gaps in doors or windows uh gaps in
walls
gaps in basements actually sometimes the
most cost-effective thing you can do is
insulate your basement which seems a
little counter-intuitive but the cold
air comes in the warm air from the house
sucks it up and you create this kind of
wind tunnel
beyond
air penetrations then i would say
increasing the r value increasing the
actual insulation in the attic and the
walls
okay thank you
okay thank you seeing no questions for
mr manning
okay representative callie pitts
it's one question that's always uh
concerned me over the decades about
whether
weatherization not necessarily complete
renovation
who once you complete a weatherization
program
is your work
judged for quality
um
and
is that done on a sporadic basis or is
it done
consistently
so if you put in new windows you put in
new blow-in air can you know
insulation
does anyone come back then and say well
yes this really
worked
that's a that's a very good question
it's it is not consistent in my
experience i don't know if others would
agree or not but
if you go through the new hampshire
saves program there generally is
engineering oversight in some regard if
you do not
i think it comes down then to the local
building code official and
uh
as you know with a state with this many
towns of varying populations and
staffing that can be
that can be hit or miss so
i will also say that we have worked with
contractors that have done a poor
quality job that we found because we
know what we're looking for
that could be something this commission
looks at is ensuring
quality oversight so we don't have
fly-by-night contractors doing a poor
job for folks
follow-up i'm just going to follow up
because i think one of the things that
was said was they were looking to ease
up the restrictions or to study the
restrictions of allowing people to do
this kind of work
um
do you think there should be something
in this commission that would also look
at results
or at work quality
i think that would be a great idea yeah
i think not only to ensure that we have
good quality work but also to
put together a retroactive analysis
should something change with the program
of the benefit against the cost
okay seeing no further questions for mr
benning we want to thank you for your
testimony here today and
i would ask representative mick williams
to let us know what the blue sheet has
to say about this bill
senate bill 269 we have eight supporting
one opposing two neutral and online
signup is open until midnight
okay with that we will close the public
hearing on senate bill 269
and we will take a
three-minute bio break before we embark
on a public hearing of senate bill 270.
well
that's
and now it's chilling
i
whatever it is
yes
so anyways
um
now
this is
please take your seats
please take your seats we're about to
resume
i'm going to open a public hearing
on senate bill 270
establishing a low moderate income
community solar program and i'd like to
introduce the prime sponsor of the bill
senator waters to introduce the bill to
us thank you senator thank you mr
chairman senator waters district 4
introducing senate bill
270 and um
let me just note as i start here that we
missed a couple technical corrections
uh in the senate and so this replace all
amendment you have why don't we just
stick with the
what you have before you the version you
already have and i'll just point out
where the couple of technical
corrections that department of energy
spotted and um
may have called but
um so this this um
bill was uh brought forward by clean
energy new hampshire um which
to discuss you know what could we do to
help the community solar program which
we passed it's in statute
what can we do to ensure that people can
actually get enrolled in the program
and um what was noticed was that they
had a mechanism down
in connecticut where eversource
obviously also has territory that
anonymized account numbers of those who
might qualify for the program could be
provided and then from those anonymized
account numbers it would be possible to
assemble
likely clusters or groups of people who
could be served
by the program so investors or others
would know where they get some bang for
their buck and work with the community
action
uh partners and and so on so um that's
what we brought forward in the
in the bill and um so what it does is it
it has a process um
here uh for identifying um
projects under the community solar
uh program um and again no real change
no real new language there just the way
the program
uh is run and then what's kind of new
here is starting on line
uh 16
where it says the department of energy
will be the
entity
that consults with electric distribution
utilities and select the means
about to enroll households as off takers
for these low moderate income community
solar projects and department of energy
said it's willing to take that on it
seemed like an efficient and simple way
to go that wouldn't require a lot of new
administration a lot of new regulations
just say they would get the account
numbers and they would figure out a a
fair and good means to
which householders would be
enrolled and as it is now um if you are
able to participate in this you're
enrolled on an opt-out basis because
basically it means you're going to get a
lot cheaper electricity coming into your
household and save you some
uh save you some money
um
now let me note the uh
changes
on line six
we forgot to take out administered by
the commission because it's administered
by the department so just we're going to
strike administered by the commission
and then down
on line 22
um
something that was recommended by the
department and by utilities
for g there
we should insert have all
reasonable and
prudently incurred costs
all reasonably and prudently incurred
cost
i mean that's kind of the standard
language
um
to see how
one would judge that there are costs
that are reasonably to be associated
with the program
and then um for the very last uh
subsection on page two
um
we needed to uh
actually just repeat the existing
statute
there and i'll just um
read what it says
the department is authorized to petition
the commission
to assess fines against revoke the
registration of
and prohibit from doing business in the
state
any group host which violates the
requirements
of this paragraph and rules adopted for
this paragraph pursuant to paragraph x
so minor change but it just thought it
would be important to mirror exactly the
existing statute on that
um so bottom line here mr chairman is
that we have a we have a program it's
been a little having a little bit slow
getting off the ground because we
haven't had an efficient way to identify
the folks who could benefit from it and
this bill will with the cooperation of
uh department of energy will let us do
that thank you mr chairman
thank you senator for introducing uh
senate bill 270 do we have questions for
the senator representative harrington is
recognized thank you mr chairman thank
you senator for taking my question
as i read this it seems to me this is a
another wealth transfer bill we're going
to everyone's going to pay higher
electric rates so certain people will
get welfare payments or subsidies to
lower their electric rate is that
correct
well um
uh let me say representative that this
is an existing program
and it has its funding as it already
exists
so it's not increasing funding
just saying given this program that
we've already passed and is in
legislation here's a way to help the
folks who qualify for it
so
you know the philosophy about whether we
ought to be doing any of this
weatherization stuff or low-income
energy stuff i mean part of the point
had been that if we're gonna if we're
gonna approve community solar which we
did
um let's make sure that it's not you
know that folks
uh who are lower income levels
get the benefit from it which is kind of
what the whole point of
system benefit charge or whatever is all
about right so follow-up
make it very quick
so in effect it is it's it's a way to
implement that program such that
everyone's going to pay a little higher
electric rates so certain people i guess
that low income is defined by being on a
wait list will get subsidies is that
correct
well
thank you for your question i don't want
to quibble over words the program is not
authorizing expenditures other than
we're already there so
whatever one may think about whether we
ought to be doing any things it's a way
for the folks who
who can qualify under the existing
program can more easily be identified
for it
okay additional questions for the
senator
representative floggie and thank you mr
chair and thank you senator waters
uh i have a question is um
the potential customers low moderate
income
is that a sign is that an opt-in or is
it the utilities going to take
information they have
without authorization of the customer
and share it with
new hampshire's uh
departments
thanks for your question so um
these customers are
i mean are in a sense they're already
identified because the utility already
knows
which accounts these are
and so
what it says is that if you qualify for
that
you might be selected
so that you can benefit
from it and get cheaper electricity you
don't have enough to go around obviously
you know the program is limited to to
what it is and the funding that what it
what it has
and so the anonymized numbers would go
out and you would receive
notice that hey you're going to get a
break in your electricity since you
qualify for the program
and if you don't want that break you can
opt out
representative samsic has a question
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
waters
could you just explain to me how this
community solar program works
are
is this
a vehicle with which then
solar installations are being built or
we buy solar energy from other sources
or
what's the solar connection here well
thanks for a question um
representative why don't i let sam evans
brown talk more about it
okay
because they've been more involved with
it
representative harrington
yeah thank you mr chairman thank you my
question senator i'm just curious the in
the middle of the on line 15 you talk
about total name plate capacity rating
of six megawatts that seems to make a
break point if it's over six megawatts
it's considered differently what's the
significance of the six megawatts is
that it's just a random number or is
there something behind that that i'm
missing
thanks for your question um i i think
sam evans brown would have something but
i think the point is that when you get
to that size of project economy scale
and you might have it might be cheaper
and so you know that's what it says hey
look if it gets up to that size um the
program would have the has the capacity
to decide which which producer they're
gonna let in because they're gonna get
better price
okay seeing those further questions for
you senator we'll let you off the hook
thank you let you get to an early lunch
another bill
or another bill
whichever is more important
all right
let's now hear from the department of
energy and ask griffin robarge to uh
give us his take on this bill
thank you chairman vos members of the
committee for the record griffin roberge
from the new hampshire department of
energy um
last week we had informed sander waters
and other interested stakeholders that
we had three technical concerns with the
bill as it came out of the senate
those
technical concerns were addressed in
this amendment that you have before you
1396 s
um
senator waters i think
went over each of the concerns that we
expressed in how they were addressed
so that really concludes my testimony
i'm happy to take any questions and uh
to be clear from the outset i didn't
mention it we are neutral on the bill um
so uh and again with that i'll take any
questions thank you
okay representative callie pitts has a
question
a little bit
confused as to how
well i can't ask a question
i'm on a sponsor so let it go i'll ask
him offline
i will ask him offline i'm a sponsor on
the bill
okay
if if we have the time yes
uh
who's next
no further questions for
the department of energy so mr roberge
thank you very much thank you
and we'll next call to the
table
sam evans brown representing clean
energy new hampshire and i'm sure mr
evans brown has a lot to offer to us
including some written testimony so
thank you
thank you mr chair thank you members of
the committee
uh so
this actually was not my idea this was
eversource's idea um
this is a pilot that was submitted in
docket 16
and it it essentially takes a program
that exists in their connecticut service
territory and scales it to new
hampshire's
market size and brings it to new
hampshire
uh and as a bit of a
reminder of the history here
the governor in 2019 in his state of the
state address
suggested that if the benefits of net
metering are going to flow
to folks who are investing in solar we
should we should investigate ways to
make that program more accessible to low
and moderate income customers
following that state of the state uh
that state of the state address
the new hampshire general court passed
what is referred to as the low to
moderate income adder which uh inc
modestly increases the net metering uh
tariff for low to moderate income
customers who are defined as 300 of the
federal excuse me i've got a frog in my
throat here
so
uh
so this is a pre-existing program it has
been identified as
as a priority by the governor to make
sure that folks who are of lower income
can benefit from the state's net
metering program that if we are going to
be providing net metering folk rates to
folks that we should that we should try
to unlock those rates for customers who
have not traditionally benefited
in the subsequent years there's been
only one project that has taken
advantage of this program
over the summer eversource conducted a
request for information trying to figure
out what was going on here
and the response they got said that it's
very difficult to identify customers
it's very difficult to identify sites
it's very difficult to coordinate
amongst all the parties who would be
required to
you know annually income verify folks
who would be eligible for this program
and indeed it's difficult to achieve
economies of scale given given the
existing confines of new hampshire's net
metering laws
and so in response as required by
legislation already
eversource put forth this pilot program
subsequently uh the the poc gave them an
extension said you've got you've got
another year to implement this pilot
program and simply all this bill does is
take a program that is already proposed
is already is already
going to be rolled out in roughly a
year's time if the poc approves it and
says let's do it we think that's a good
idea
so
i think it's a pretty modest proposal
it's one that has been proven out in
other places
eversource themselves say they think
this is a very administratively
efficient way of doing this
um and the the privacy concerns which i
think are very valid ones are most most
aptly addressed by letting the
department of energy and the utilities
coordinate in such a way so that so that
the the account information of these
already identified income eligible
customers does not
you know become public knowledge in any
possible way
and the the bill as written attempts to
allow
uh the the doe and the utilities to
figure out how to do that
so
that's all i really have to say um again
as i said this was not my idea i'm
simply saying let's do it
and i'll happily take any questions
great so
thank you for that testimony
from clean energy new hampshire um did
you have a
something to say go ahead
i am a co-sponsor though so can i ask it
anyway
you have plenty of time so go ahead okay
thank you for taking my question
um
so the question is around it sounds like
from your description
that this is
to facilitate an administrative
procedure that would allow the program
to be more successful because they're
having difficulty reaching people
who might benefit or who we're trying to
reach so is that
that how you would describe what we're
doing here it's an administrative
improvement yes correct i mean the the
difficulty has been identifying low to
moderate income eligible customers uh
and b given that the utilities have a
list of customers who are who are
definitely qualified so the list would
come from the electric assistance
program which are folks who are who are
definitely below the 300
federal poverty rate line in fact most
of them are below the actual poverty
line right so so this is definitely
sending the credit to the the the
population that is most in need of a
little help
uh so
so it is it is
uh un you know is unlocking a program
that already exists and and helping it
to get off the ground and i'll just
follow up i know representative samsuch
had the question earlier of the
explanation of the solar piece and you
just mentioned the credits so
what's happening is it sounds like the
governor's request in his state of the
state
that we be able to figure out a way to
take solar advantages and make sure
they're distributed to people who are
in the low income
uh register that that's
that's what you're talking about that's
exactly what i'm talking about and in
fact it would result in the development
of new projects essentially if if you
were a solar developer you would uh
identify a project as being one that
would be eligible for these types of off
takers uh you would coordinate with the
department of energy who would then uh
take your project and and assign off
takers to it from this list of of income
eligible folks that that again the
utilities have already assembled because
they're the participants in the electric
assistance program
um and
uh
yeah
okay thanks next uh representative
lewicki has a question okay thank you mr
chairman thank you um
i'm trying to understand the mechanics
of this and where does the capital come
from because somebody has to invest and
clearly the people who benefit are not
in a position to invest and how would
they get their pay back
that's a an excellent question um and so
solar developers would have to find the
capital to to invest up front in these
projects and and uh the the department
would i mean essentially they would get
paid back the same way that that any
solar development gets paid back is that
you'd have a host who who either is
paying the upfront cost themselves and
then receiving the benefits or you'd
have some sort of third party ownership
arrangement in which
you know if for instance if the host is
not eligible for tax credits it is often
the case that that a third-party entity
will own the project and arrange to sell
the power through a power purchase
agreement and so that would that would
depend on the hosts who depend on the
situation but essentially it would be
developed the same way any solar project
is developed the question of
how to meet out the bill credits to the
off takers that is the question that
would be delegated to the department of
energy
as opposed to being determined by the
the site host
representative thomas has a question
thank you mr chairman and
thank you for your test point
in difference to the fact that you've
mentioned that this is eversource's idea
would it be possible perhaps if
eversource could come up here and maybe
explain their program because these
questions seem to be being asked of you
of how that program works it's not up to
me i mean i don't know if donna is
prepared to speak to the program because
it does if you're if you're interested i
can forward along the program design
which has been filed at the public
utilities uh commission i have it here
in front of me but i i don't know if
donna has studied up on on the program
so she may not uh i may actually be
better positioned to answer them in this
i see okay
you
well that's my question was i
it was their idea so often i thought
that they might have come up here and
just spoken just for a minute or two on
the overall synopsis of it but if
they're not if the
if the right person is not here for it
that's fine i just made the suggestion
harrington is recognized for a question
thank you mr chairman i think you're
taking my question i'm a little confused
at the how this works so i'm going to at
first i'm going to start with the
hopefully the easy question uh the six
megawatts i asked senator was there any
significance to that six megawatts in
aggregate so it's not that would not be
an individual project that would be
allowed to be six megawatts in size but
but that's that's essentially a cap on
the program and that's that's again
that's taken from eversource's proposal
before the puc okay that's where it
comes from right follow-up
so
now okay so i'm a low-income electric
user and it says i'm going to be mailed
to something that says if if i don't do
anything because it's opt out i will be
given credits
how where were these credits coming from
the credits essentially are would are
generated in the exact same way that
that any group net metered project
generates bill credits right so we have
an existing mechanism through which you
you
divvy out the production of a facility
to to off takers um and if you you know
if you'd like you can grab the form off
the pc's website it's it's pretty simple
it essentially says here's the here's
the account here's the percentage of the
of the production that is going to be
credited to that account um and and in
in the proposal before the puc
uh the the idea was to divide those
those credits up in such a way that each
customer would receive about 240 worth
of bill credit per year uh so that you'd
maximize the number of people who could
credit who could who could benefit from
an individual project um and but there
is there is going to be a certain amount
of of you know
figuring out how much credit should an
individual customer get because they're
not they're not involved in you know
paying for the project themselves which
which is often the case in community
solar projects you sort of pay into them
in this instance the bill credit would
be determined by the department of
energy
okay the follow-up done that because i'm
just i'm trying to follow the money sure
so i understand
what you just said but
who is actually paying with the credits
come from somebody somebody has to open
their wallet out and say this is 240
okay here's my share who who is paying
that and how is it collected so in in
this instance it would again the the
project would likely be developed by a
third party
um they would perhaps have a an on-site
load that they're they're offsetting
um and that that third-party developer
would would have to have to
look at the the amount of reimbursement
that they're getting from the sale of
the energy and determine if that's a
reasonable return on their capital um if
they want to develop it or not uh so so
it's
it's essentially like any other
community solar project you know you'd
have to you have to find a source of
capital you have to find a site and then
but the the the only difference is here
the off takers are are outsourced to
this eap list so they would be then
receiving the uh up till was 100
kilowatts they'd get the full rate and
then above that it would be just the
energy person
portion the default service rate right
so that's exactly right it would work it
i mean it changes nothing about the net
metering status all right thank you
representative callie pitts
my concern on this one
and i am a co-sponsor my concern was the
privacy of
knowing
who and who is not a low-income user and
who has that information and to whom
it's going to be given
i
also
i i would imagine that i and i know this
program is for single home owners it's
not for apartments not for housing
authorities
which would be very interesting is that
that information
going to be divulged
from say housing authorities or other
entities
yeah so i actually think it could it
could flow to any electric account that
that is already receiving benefits
through the electric assistance program
so it may it may be to apartment um
dwellers or or folks in the housing
authorities i
i would not know because those the list
of who's on the eap is not public um and
i would imagine
that it wouldn't be terribly difficult
for the utilities to to share enough
information with the department of
energy for for the doe to determine
uh you know who the off takers or how
many off takers they're going to be and
and uh and what the bill credit should
be without having to share any any
private information for instance it
could be it could you could they could
come up with it's similar to how testing
happens in the schools you could come up
with sort of an identifier that's not
associated with the accounts in any
other way and and you know how much
what's the electric bill you know the
typical load associated with this
identifying number and you know that but
but the the bill intends to uh you know
the the question of did we do what we
intend to do is always a fair one but
the bill intends to leave that mechanism
up to the department of energy and the
utilities to determine how to do it in a
way that protects everyone's privacy
representative partial
thank you sir voice
um
just so i can
get my mind wrapped around already who
may already be qualified for this
program
if i am not receiving any energy uh bill
support from the utility currently
could i still
apply
to benefit from this program if i were
income eligible
uh so certainly it is the case that
anyone who's income eligible is already
eligible to receive the load of modern
income adder onto from from a net
metered project uh the the problem has
been assembling enough of those
customers into a block to do a community
solar project that actually is you know
financiable
uh which is the problem the bill aims to
solve uh
that said uh folks folks my
understanding is that folks typically
learn about the electric assistance
program mostly through the the community
action programs um and so there there
are income eligible customers out there
who are not going to be on this list uh
and and there are folks who who we would
want to either
direct to sign up which i think
that's what the community action
programs are doing all the time is
trying to get everyone who's income
eligible onto their the electric
assistance program um but also you know
if if we are successful in getting uh
the low to moderate income solar program
up and running
we we may find that that solar
developers
are able to to you know through more
traditional means start to identify
income qualified customers who could
serve as off takers for projects and
maybe could do some sort of hybrid
arrangement between
um you know a program that's finding its
customers through
a project that's finding its customers
through this program as well as those
more traditional means
and i would assume that would include
word of mouth as well
i think that's how most folks learn yeah
okay
representative harrington has one last
question really quick you in your
handout you said but to date no projects
taking advantage of this ad have been
completed and i think you stated there
was one so one is correct yeah that is
uh
that was a mistake in the testimony
thank you
see no further questions for mr sam
evans brown we thank you mr evans brown
for being here
and uh
i would ask
representative lewis to give us the blue
sheet recommendations okay on the blue
sheet we have 49 in support zero opposed
zero neutral and that's it
thank you very much
with that
we'll close the public hearing on senate
bill 270 and we will recess
this session until one o'clock
so everyone enjoy your lunch
view here assembled we will be starting
the public hearing on
sb 395 in about five minutes
you
we're waiting for the bill's sponsor
senator khan
he's on his way so we'll be starting
this public hearing very soon
you
for those watching at home we're still
waiting for senator khan who will
introduce
senate bill 395 he should be here
momentarily
okay now we can proceed
i will open a public hearing on senate
bill 395
which is
an act
relative to the broadband matching grant
initiative and i will introduce the
bill's primary sponsor
senator jay kahn welcome senator to sdne
thank you
please turn on your mic please thank you
um
yes thank you mr chairman
members
of uh
the
house
energy
committee
uh science and
yeah science technology
i'm getting there
i'll get to my notes
so folks
thing that
motivates this
legislation motivated the senate to
support this legislation
uh is the fact that you can drive about
anywhere in new hampshire and
find dead spots
where you drop calls
cellular service is
as
it may touch many communities in the
state but many of those served
communities
have spotty service it's inconsistent
and
we've been at this for a long time
trying to solve this issue
and uh
so it this exists in cheshire county
this exists in the north country this uh
i've got an
email yesterday from somebody from beau
uh
uh indicating that it's in uh there as
well
i was driving down to boston one day
past derry
and
i
told senator uh
that
i had my my call dropped the as i was
driving through dairy
uh
so
it's uh
we have
these spots throughout new hampshire uh
so we need to address it we need to find
some way to do it whether
the opportunity comes from federal money
uh or it comes from state uh funds
somewhere down the fro the road or it
comes
through partnerships that providers and
the state can enter into
this is an important thing to do so
this is enabling legislation it's not
requiring an allocation at this time
but
it's important to to to make some
progress here so
that's what 395 attempts to do
is provide us with the opportunity to
establish
a fund
this says within the
broadband
fund which we
established through hb2 in this last
biennium
there will be an amendment
and i hope to work with
you mr chairman
to bring that amendment forward
that will define
this process more thoroughly
and it's been a really good opportunity
to work with the providers
with the wireless carriers in the state
of new hampshire
to talk about this uh initiative in more
detail
and uh where this is leading is that uh
rather than
uh
establishing multiple purposes or
technology developments through the
broadband fund
is to establish a
a wireless services
deployment
initiative so that is what the fund
would be labeled
to dedicate dollars towards a wireless
deployment initiative
uh
the
uh the need for this is is clear uh
when i was visiting with
uh a town in my district
uh the police chief in that smaller town
seventeen hundred people uh
indicated that they could receive nine
one one calls but when they made the
effort to contact the person in distress
they were unable to make that call
so there are safety reasons we've lived
through a pandemic and we know that
there are workplace
health care and education reasons
that we need a more robust wireless
technology deployment in the state
and
[Music]
you know this is an opportunity whether
it comes through federal dollars that
are available to us or state dollars
that are available because
the states
got surplus dollars
just establishing the fund will give us
that mechanism
uh and the vehicle through which this uh
a more robust distribution can occur
if you're familiar with the broadband
fund the business and economic affairs
is taking the leadership on this that
was what was delegated through hb2
and
they are aware of this uh initiative and
waiting to see how the legislature deals
with it
uh
but i think that
the the infrastructure that the state
has set up through their broadband fund
would also be the infrastructure that
could be
depended upon to carry out this
initiative as well
be glad to answer any questions the
committee
thank you senator before i take
questions from the other members of the
committee
i would like to
apologize to the other members of the
committee for not having some amendment
language to present to them today i
thought maybe we would
but it doesn't look like
the draft was completed in time for us
to present it to the committee today
i have worked with senator khan and some
members of the
the industry to develop this draft and i
will send it to other members of the
committee as soon as it is complete
which i expect will be by the end of day
today
and
then we'll be able to inspect it
essentially what it does it sets up a
wireless
matching grant initiative
very similar to one that already exists
for broadband which is hardwired this is
simply a wireless
grant initiative
and
with that i will now
uh encourage members of the committee to
ask the senator questions and recognize
representative thomas
thank you mr chair uh thank you senator
for taking my question that this
question might be better directed
towards maybe one of the providers but
my question just for clarification by
setting up this grant fund
and since the word granted you a grant
to me usually means a one-time payment
from from from the government so
if we were to set up additional cell
service using the grant would it be the
responsibility of the providers to
hope that the customer base that they
get from this will pay for their their
expenses from here on in or would they
be picking up an area where it might be
a losing proposition once the grant
money runs out i just don't not quite
sure how that works but that's that's
the only concern i have on that have the
providers come to you to tell them to
tell you how how they would work that
we have had that conversation uh
representative thomas and
it's it's a very good question and i
think you should pursue that with the
providers my
feeling on this is that
there
is a mixture
of uh where
[Music]
there are some areas that are unserved
because there is
not much revenue to be derived
to pay back that investment
there are other areas like in dairy uh
where if that needs to be deployed in a
more robust manner uh
the customer base is is uh you know
clearly much deeper
so
but i think it's envisioned that the
grant dollars would provide the
infrastructure investment
thank you
representative harrington has a question
and thank you mr chairman i thank you
for taking my question senator um
actually a couple
it says in uh line three here a
municipality is located in an area that
is determined to lack adequate cell
phone service
so is i correct in assuming that if you
have a municipality and any portion of
that is lacking cell phone service that
the municipality would be eligible for
the grants
yes
that's that's the way that
and so
in the amendment that you're going to
see
it's both for unserved areas and areas
that have inconsistent service
if you
think about i mean
one of the towns i represent
it would be nelson new hampshire
nelson has you can get cell service in
some spots of nelson in about two-thirds
of nelson you can't get cell phone
service so
it's uh
the it it it needs to uh recognize both
unserved and areas that are served
inconsistently
okay follow up mr chairman follow up
yeah well that's what i'm trying to get
straight because let's just say for
example i'm the town i live in is
traffic we have the same situation some
areas get very good coverage some have
zero coverage so if i can go to a
whatever town and wander around with a
cell phone and find some one location
that doesn't get service does that mean
that the whole town is now eligible for
the grant money
but what's the criteria for doing that
simply a single location only or
it's envisioned and and again that
the providers i think understand their
technology best uh you know you put up a
tower you put up some type of wireless
uh receiver it's not quite it likely
will have overlapping uh
with with something that
that it currently provides some service
yeah i recognize the issue that you're
stating
the
a lot of this needs to get sorted out
through the
uh or the rule making process
and
in the rulemaking process the bea will
need to identify what will be the
criteria for reward
so i think the
part of the that criteria would be the
extent to which it's providing service
to areas that are currently not served
is that sufficient representative
further questions for senator khan
representative callie pitts
senator khan thank you for taking my
questions if my mind
is not all shot
i seem to remember that we
provided legislation whereby
municipalities
could
bond
for broadband
uh
years ago
and that one of the problems was that
there were the money it was just much
too expensive
and not enough customers to do the
infrastructure for the companies to make
it worth their while
so this grant
please if i'm understanding it right
would pay for that infrastructure
what then
who would own that infrastructure who
would be responsible for maintenance of
that infrastructure
and would the town or the
municipality or a group of
municipalities who get together
be able to
control the rates on that particular
line
thank you representative um
the
it's because this is an important
clarification i think um
the
ownership would be with the providers
the maintenance would be with the
providers
i think this operates a little bit
differently because this service is not
to a point of delivery
a wired service you know is going to a
point
to be served
to that residence to that business
it is
to the door
back to
a central hub right
the so the town it makes sense for a
town to be participating in that
and and actually
i'm seeing my my neighbor from
marlborough representative partial
and and uh his town has recently uh
elected to bond
uh and that's a small
community uh
so
we we've had good success with that
broadband fund because it is wired to a
user and you
i think the companies have figured out a
long-term return on that investment
this is different
because it's not bounded by town
territories
and it's not wired directly to a
specific user
and and so it's likely to be providers
that are seeking these grants and the
town's control will be through the
permitting process
any kind of tower any kind of
structure that needs to be
deployed
as part of expanding the service area
is is going to be controlled by a town
and the town's participation in this is
going to be through its permitting
process
follow-up
peace
i
i just want to try to get my head around
this i have a t
and one of the
cheapest plants
because i'm a cheap person
that is a wireless service
but it is directed
at me
and i pick up my own
bill i pay my own bill for that
so
that indeed is
directed at a customer is it not is this
are we talking about the same thing
so
that service would have to be directed
toward a customer am i correct
the customer would have to elect
to take that service and then be billed
and pay
for whatever
capacity or whatever they want on that
service is that correct yes thank you
yes and and hopefully in the amendment
that you see it'll
begin to indicate what some of the award
criteria need to be
in the rule making process
so that
the extent to which
a state grant is covering
the costs and the extent to which a
provider can make that investment
so to give you a sense of
what the amendment will say it says that
there is hereby established within the
department of business and economic
affairs a wireless grant initiative
the purpose of which shall be to provide
grants to wireless providers in order to
improve wireless connectivity within
communities and across the state
and
it says that eligible projects shall
include provide shall provide wireless
infrastructure in areas that lack
mobile wireless coverage
an eligible project you'll be evaluated
as part of a competitive prod process
selected projects shall meet the needs
of consumers with the lowest possible
cost and the highest possible
functionality
that gives you a flavor of what the
amended language will
will say it's much more specific
than the bill we're reading
here this afternoon
representative lewicki has a question uh
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
um
you mentioned dropped calls
this
my impression is that people aren't
supposed to be on their cell phones
while they're driving and
that's at least what the sign i saw when
i got on the state highway said so would
this not encourage people in areas where
rural to actually be doing more of what
we've outlawed
um
you know it it it says you're not
supposed to be handling your cell phone
and
i just as somebody who
uses hand-free devices
in
my vehicle i
cover a lot of miles coming to and from
concord
i think
it it uh
it's pretty difficult for me to complete
a phone call
uh
and
you know it's totally hands-free i can
i can say i'd like to
contact representative lewicki
uh
no i don't have your phone number
but you understand
okay thank you senator i my phone is in
the car and if it rings when i'm in the
car i don't answer it
rep representative mcgee has recognized
request thank you mr chairman and thank
you senator khan for taking my question
um we had a bill earlier this session on
relieving the telecom carriers of last
resort in certain areas and part of the
testimony that we had was that cell
cell receptivity was pretty much
ubiquitous now so that people had
coverage all over new hampshire and
you're testifying here today that that's
still not quite the case so it sounds to
me like it's a it's a good bill and it's
a good idea to do um
so the question would be is is the
intent then to ensure
that there is sufficient funding to try
and fill
those gaps that still exist for people
to have basically universal service in
the state
yes
yes it is
that
you know we're going to achieve that
someday through broadband
uh but it doesn't deal with the mobile
device and while some people might use
it from a car other people are going to
use it from their workplace and we know
through
i chair the telehealth services
commission of the state
uh we know that that
so many
uh
what has helped the behavioral
uh uh
mental health services in the state
is the ability for people to make their
appointments not leave the workplace
uh
and and not have to travel uh and
wireless connectivity is essential for
that
uh it's the same way with with students
uh trying to
access from any place after school
program uh and be able to access their
assignments
um
so i i think uh
uh yeah
that this
this need for universal coverage that
you've referenced
is going to be met not just by
land-based connectivity
uh wire to wire
service but through wireless services as
well
and i would just follow follow up
my understanding is for a lot of people
not of my generation
um is that they don't have landlines
right they only have the cell which is
another reason why that ubiquity is is
going to be
more necessary for competition in terms
of the state's
even business basis because a lot of
people are not reachable by a landline
anymore and they're not connecting their
homes in that way unless it's for their
computers
so um
it would seem like this
the platform of the cell or the cellular
receptivity it needs to be addressed
maybe even more urgent urgently because
of the way people use the technology
today i think i think your perceptions
right on uh
if you
i know a realtor has
taken me aside
and said
i lost a customer this weekend because
they pulled out their cell phone and
tried to make a call and couldn't from
this location so
yeah
that ubiquitous
uh that sense of that that people come
to new hampshire and expect
and and and
uh we we are losing people because
the lack thereof
so
senator kahn i have a question for you
it's been reported that new hampshire
will receive something
in the neighborhood of 150 122 or 150
million dollars in federal funds
to expand broadband
infrastructure if this wireless
initiative
grant
fund is established
could it apply for grants
some of those federal grants
or some of that federal grant money
could it be used for this
initiative
i
don't know
um
that clearly is
uh would be
an important
bit of information to to be certain of
and and maybe providers can can answer
that more thoroughly
it requires a certain performance
level and meaning bandwidth
i don't know that wireless
services can meet all of those
requirements
but those rules are in the process of
being written and aren't available right
now to answer definitively your question
okay thank you representative partial
yes thank you and uh good afternoon uh
um
my
concern
i guess you'd say is that hearing the
discussion about um
how
young people tend to use broadband
services uh
wireless services which tend to be
broadband they tend to be watching their
movies and they tend to be doing a lot
of things that require a lot of
and
then with broadband money coming into
the state
i see the real concern personally is
that we need to be able to ensure 9-1-1
coverage throughout the state
um and i'm not married to that being a
5g servicer or what they sometimes call
a wireless broadband service
i'm my big concern is making sure that
no matter where you are in the state you
can access emergency services
um
is there any type of guarantee that
you're aware of that would put this as a
priority for this bill going forward
i
again i think the rules will need to
define
uh
the priority of service
um
i believe
uh firstnet
t wireless is in the room
and you might want to ask uh
more specifically that question i will
do then thank you so much
representative mirner has a question
yes just to follow up on um
what the chairman suppose said um i'm in
coast county and they applied for a
study we gave them some study money for
the funds to you can't hardwire koaz
county it's huge it's top third of the
state and putting these towers up with
the 5g that we're talking about
the solution so i'm hoping that
this 140 million dollars that chairman's
talking about is available to these real
rural areas because i could never see it
being wired up there
i don't even think 140 million would
cover it
so i hope that gets included in the
in that when that money comes forth yes
i think the balance between unserved and
inconsistently served is going to be one
of those tension points
that's going to need to be worked out
through that rfp right and and the the
value of
how do you value
uh different proposals thank you senator
representative pimentel has a question
thank you mr chairman thank you
senator khan i
my concern is basically
i guess it gets down to the rule making
and who's going to make them
two towns where you brought up
derry and
nelson
in derry you've got a fairly large
population
and more
towers could be added there
and be profitable
without
grant money
whereas in nelson
there's
a place that would definitely need grant
money
to make it work
um
so how do you separate to keep
the
these easy projects that are going to be
profitable anyway from taking the money
off the top pretty much
i i think you're
you're
zeroing in on on an issue that
uh
you know we we ought to
it shouldn't stand in the way of what
this initiative is trying to do
but it does need to be a part of the
prioritization
in awards you know i i i understand
that
providers
and their participation in an overall
project
it differs between
where
the potential for earnings
and
the potential for
serving unserved
uh need to be valued differently
okay thank you
representative callie pitts
being an old-timer and
also having a landline which i don't
think i'd ever give up
um
i'm reading the bill and it says
a municipality is determined to lack
adequate self-service now i'm thinking
of something that we did
quite a few years ago
with unh
getting a grant to do the last mile and
what it turned out to be was just upping
speeds because adequate service
has a very defined definition it can be
people who have service that don't have
enough speed
it can be defined many ways
you are on a commission with your
commission that it's on the broadband
commission for this the governor
would you see or
be looking into that to see what the
parameters are and be involved in the
rulemaking
for this particular
process
uh
i i'm not sure how the department of
business economic affairs would would
carry out its rulemaking uh
i you know
i don't know that there's a broadband
commission in the state i don't think
that there is
the commission that i chair is on
telehealth services which is very
concerned
with the ability for people to have cell
service so that
those appointments that
people have with physicians or mental
health providers
can occur
without problem in the same way that the
safety concern
uh
you know uh but
um
yeah i i i understand
the uh
you know where where your concern is
there
okay senator khan thank you uh if we
have i'm just going to add that i was
very
involved with carol miller on that
and
and that was a middle mile service i
mean there were only two communities
two communities had enfield and uh
rindge i believe were the two
uh communities that had last mile
service
allocated to that otherwise that was
i mean that infrastructure will serve us
well with broadband deployment
thank you senator khan we have to move
on i know the committee may have further
questions but we need to
hear from representatives from a t and t
so i'd like to call
owen
smith
to testify on this bill
and committee members he will have
answers to a lot of your additional
questions i'm sure so mr smith
please turn the microphone back on
i said i hope that's the case i think i
was able to sitting back there answer
most of them but
happy to do that so uh
chair voz
vice chair thomas members of the
committee uh i appreciate the
opportunity to be here
to comment uh in support of this concept
of of creating a wireless
deployment grant fund
my name is owen smith i'm with at t i'm
the state president for the northern new
england maine new hampshire and vermont
and i'd first like to bring attention to
a letter that i think ctia has submitted
i don't know if you have it yet i think
it was done maybe later
this morning
earlier this morning but i just wanted
to highlight a couple of things this is
from the cellular telephone
industry association which is for the
wireless providers
they write in support of creation of a
wireless deployment grant initiative and
its respective fund which is yet to be
determined
the importance of wireless is also
highlighted in 2020 during covid
wireless data traffic
had another record year
and since 2016
data has increased by 207 percent
according to the national center for
health statistics in the last six months
of 2020
65.8 percent of adults and 75.5 percent
of children lived in households with
wireless only voice services
here in new hampshire it's about half
of the population is with a
just a wireless household no no landline
connection whatsoever
so um anyway the ctia applause the
committee's effort uh for the creation
of a wireless deployment grant in that
respective fund so i just wanted to
highlight
that if i if i could
so
um
so we appreciate um the intent of
senator khan and have worked with him on
the amendment that he has referenced
along with with others
and
that would be
the industry has worked along with
myself from att
and
i think it's important that
we we take the bill that senator khan
has introduced and make it sort of more
defined
a more robust opportunity in creating
a separate fund for wireless and with
some some guidance that the bea would
through a rulemaking process be putting
together
some key elements should include a
separate fund for wireless
for various reasons establish a
competitive rfp process for the wireless
providers establish a challenge process
that where questions and answers can be
had after the process and ensure
proprietary information is protected
we're a very competitive industry and
that information
we would like to see protective and then
a process that would promote
um a wireless connectivity statewide
and
so just the last couple of years we've
realized how reliant we've become
on broadband and wireless communications
with covid
you know the wireless networks were
performed very well as did the broadband
networks uh the wired the wire line um
the wireless had an increase of 25 to 30
percent
um literally overnight when when cove
hit back in i think it was march of 2019
and
so
that's i think important to to state
so it's important that we
put an initiative together and address
the areas in new hampshire using federal
funding that would
lack adequate mobile wireless service
so
there are federal dollars that have come
to the state there are more coming
a lot of the funds
[Music]
are open to interpretation on whether or
not they can be used what they can be
used for whether it's wireless
or or or not there are some specific
speeds and in some cases wireless cannot
meet those
there seems to be
a
out for public safety
that doesn't tie
to specific speeds and of course 5g
coming
will be able to meet some of those
speeds unlike a 4g lte can today
so just
looking at new hampshire and
specifically now with a t over the last
three years we've invested 120 million
dollars in this state on our network and
a lot of that had to do with uh firstnet
which is a public safety network that
we have a contract with the federal
government over a 25-year period
we're going to be investing 40 billion
dollars and
we've
done a lot in new hampshire and across
the country with that funding
here in new hampshire since 2018
we've
turned on well over 50 cell sites
and
those benefit both the att commercial
customers and public safety with
firstnet when a site is built and when
all is said and done and it's up and
running
both the att's customers and first
responders will benefit
so we've put coverage in towns lots of
towns but towns like jeffrey and antrim
stoddard
stewart's town westchesterfield
bath
and and you know 50 50 more
some of those
really were
areas that needed improved coverage that
had some coverage
but that list that i just read really
didn't have any coverage and uh i'm
happy to say that i can now drive from
keene to concord and not drop a call
i couldn't say that 18 months ago
so um
with all that said there are still towns
nelson was was mentioned um that would
still like to have and need better cell
coverage
um one of the points that was
asked or questions that was asked here
um
you know people shouldn't be making
calls in their in your cars
the majority of calls that are made on a
cell phone are made inside of a building
the majority of
are done on a cell 911
so this isn't about teenagers driving
around
you know texting which they shouldn't be
doing um but some do and we know that
that's an issue but this is this is a
much bigger piece
in that again more than 22 percent or
excuse me more than 50 percent of new
hampshire
residents
use wireless only for their connectivity
so
all of that investment that we've done
120 million over the next over the last
three years and more will be coming but
there's um we still have a ways to go
and nelson was mentioned dairy we've got
a couple of sites and dairies you know
it's going to be
specific by carrier i don't think we
have an issue in dairy new hampshire
with a network
but there are towns that we do and
but there's areas
and maybe nelson is one of them where
the
return on investment is not there
and at t is going to put a very low
priority on that versus trying to get
more capacity in manchester or boston
and with firstnet
we didn't have a return on investment to
worry about we've got sites out there
that we've spent two million dollars on
that we will never get a return on
investment but we also got some federal
money on that and we've committed to
build out the network
and the return on investment didn't
matter
so we're in a situation now where
a lot of these hard to find places will
first net cover those at some point some
of them perhaps we're just starting to
talk about the next round of funding but
many of those places providers are just
not going to go to because there is no
return
on investment
so um
i think that does it for me but um thank
you again for taking up this important
point and we would certainly
um encourage you to pass a bill that
would support something like this
thank you
appreciate that yep representative
partial has a question
thank you chair uh thank you for coming
and take my question
um
my concern is a place like nelson where
you may not get that return on
investment and i know you're you have a
responsibility to your shareholders
but at the same time there's a
good for the state it's good for the
community to have this 9911 connectivity
it's a public safety issue i figure
and my concern would be
because you're focusing on broadband
with uh
at least by meeting this letter and has
a very strong focus on providing
broadband service
wireless service for the state
my concern is a place like nelson will
continue to be underserved
and
or places like that that are really
not financially feasible for a company
that does need to turn a profit to serve
and i see this bill as a means the
intent of the bill is a means to get
around that to make sure we get adequate
coverage throughout the state
um
do you believe this bill can be tweaked
in such a way so we can ensure coverage
in these uh
less profitable areas
absolutely and and i think that's why
this bill is so important
again uh first net aside
att
has to prioritize our budgets start on a
national level and then they come into
new england and then new hampshire you
know based on subscribers and that kind
of thing um but we've got to prioritize
where we um want to go and spend that
money and although we would love to have
continuous coverage throughout
everywhere in new hampshire we don't i
don't think anybody i know no provider
does um
the terrain is tough so
you know a situation like nelson
basically the the grant would pay for
all of the capital costs
of a sell site
and an average sell site depending on
the provider for a t
it's about 400 to 450 000
so that's all this grant would do um is
is provide the capital cost to do that
once it's up and running
you know the return on investment is
still important you know we have uh
leases
typically at t or verizon wouldn't own
that cell site we would get a third
party to build that
we may take it through the permitting
process but hand it over sell it to a
third party and then they would be
responsible for we would become they
would be the landlord we would become a
customer you know verizon u.s cellular
t-mobile could also jump on that site um
so
there are ongoing expenses operating
expenses but you you blend that site
into the you know 400 other sites that
we have in new hampshire and uh you know
you look at it as a total
so
follow up
i'm not sure if it's that actually a
follow-up or maybe some content um
att
may come in as a better for a place like
nelson which is dear to me because i
have lost self-coverage in nelson when i
really desperately needed it i think
abdina was a story here um
but um
if i'm on a strip network or verizon or
any other network
that necessarily means that does not
necessarily mean i can still have
adequate cell phone coverage in nelson
because i'm on their own network i mean
that is correct right
that's correct um i have a caveat
regarding 9-1-1 i'd love to hear it so
if there is anybody's network there
and you were dialing 9-1-1 it would go
to whatever network
that was there so if verizon was in
um
you know nelson
and you were an att customer in dialed
9-1-1 it would be picked up through
that's reassuring thank you thank you
representative callie pitts has a
question
yeah my question is is on this bill
and i think something that
representative votes read
from a possible amendment confused me
who actually would apply for this bill
would it be the town or would it be the
provider and is that money or was it the
state and then the state goes to the
town and goes to the i mean it's just
very convoluted to me
and then the last lines of the bill
eight and nine i go back to the adequate
cell phone service which could mean
many towns not just the ones that have
gaps
so
depending on who picks
who gets the money
somebody picks the town or the place so
i'd like to know that who who
who actually applies for the grant from
the federal government
and or the state government
so that would be the provider in and
in senator khan's bill 395 um that's one
of the areas that has
in the process i guess of being amended
um
that's sort of how the broadband
networks work the wire line um i know i
think consolidated has gone into you
know partnership with municipalities um
that really can't happen with with
wireless
you need to own spectrum which the
wireless providers do in order to put up
a network a wireless network that will
work with the other providers so
it's very much driven by
the provider not the municipality so the
provider would own all of the equipment
and be responsible for the upkeep of all
of that equipment
may i follow up follow up
ownership is something i understand but
it's a application for the grant itself
and then it if
the provider
applies for the grant it would who would
pick out which areas are going to be
served and it may not be those who are
not served at all
it may be those who are underserved so
who actually makes the federal
application
so it would be um the provider that
would that would
that would work and again these rules
all need to be worked out through bea um
so i don't know exactly how it would
work but that's obviously first and
foremost but my understanding is
that the the provider would apply for
those grants and it would be in a
particular area listen we know our
network we know where there's holes
right um uh and
we would we would certainly work with a
community which we we do through the
permitting process so we would let's say
go to
a bea and and say you know we would like
to apply for a grant for nelson
we then have to go to nelson
and nelson sort of wants to
needs to to want it and we need to work
through
the permitting process that is already
in place with the town of nelson where
we show them
you know our great coverage around
across route 9. i think nelson's on
route 9 right yeah and uh but that we
have a gap in coverage in the village of
nelson maybe not out on the highway so
we we
have our propagation maps we have the
propagation of the site that we would be
proposing in nelson and
we would be looking for a permit from
the town which we would then take back
to to be a bea and say
here you go
and that's i believe when we would get
the funding
okay before we move on i'm going to open
the public hearing on senate bill 424
fn
and recess that public hearing until
we're done with this one
all right further questions
representative berezni
thank you for taking my question it's a
two-part question the first one is uh is
firstnet intended to cover all of new
hampshire do you know and then the
second one is where atnt offers
service because of firstnet is that only
calls or does that include broadband as
well so great great question um you know
the mandate that we have
with firstnet the first net authority
which is
uh under ntia
is a a mandate to build out a robust
network for first responders that that
first responder it's a separate network
from the att
core network we
currently are running two networks in
new hampshire actually more than that
with our fiber but from a wireless
standpoint we have the att network and
we have the the firstnet core network
there are shared services and
shared spectrum um between those two but
they are two separate networks um this
is
a broadband network with voice
capabilities
so it is absolutely both on every single
um cell site that both commercial
customers and first responders can take
advantage of
i don't think we have a mandate to cover
a hundred percent of the state um we we
already cover well over 95 percent of
the population um and we'll continue to
get it 100 of the population um
i can't sit here and tell you because
this is all line of sight that that we
will ever get
through this technology
of of macro towers around the state
where we or anybody else would cover 100
percent of the state of new hampshire or
any other state
you know if you're behind a big rock in
nelson you know you may not be getting
coverage
so it'll be darn close
representative harrington has a question
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um just trying to
clarify the bill a little bit here in my
mind because we keep talking people keep
talking about it'll be done in rules i
prefer that we put it in the bill what
we want is our intent so
first question would be it appears that
the municipality can apply for a grant
and then use that money to hire a
communication provider or the
communications provider can apply for
the grant with the concurrence of the
governing body of municipality so
there's two different methods for
getting the grant
the way the bill is written yes but i
think that's part of the amendment that
will be coming out that will that will
build a municipality yes
and this follow-up and then in the
second part is i'm still
a little confused on it meets federal
standards for speed lacing latency
reliability and consistency is there a
defined thing somewhere in the federal
code of federal regulations or something
that tells me what that is there is not
so
the bill that has to be amended in the
bill because it's a standard that
anybody or nobody could meet because you
don't know what it is
well that's that's a federal guidance
and and and there is no definition of a
wireless broadband um
i don't think they're they point to
speeds or you know latency or capacity
or anything like that
and and i think one of the reasons is
that if you've got a cell site in
uh nelson it sounds like we're gonna
have to get a sell site nelson but
you get a have a sell site in nelson um
if they're if you've got an event going
on you know a
town
you know fair whatever and there's
hundreds of people in nelson um there
may be some capacity issues um not for
first responders because of first net
but there could be some capacity issues
um there could be um
uh some some some coverage issues
compared to where there may only be
the normal what's the population of
nelson 250 people i don't know
so so it varies so much on the the
traffic
uh in in usage and number of people
that it's tough to pin down a definition
for a wireless broadband but but as far
as what we have here adequate cell phone
service it's not defined in the bill and
what you're telling me it's not to find
any place else either right all right
thank you
all right it will be defined in the
amendment to read as follows it will
read
selected projects shall meet the needs
of customers with the lowest possible
cost and the highest possible
functionality
which admittedly is
not terribly precise but
that's what the amendment calls for
all right
i think uh
we will have time for one more question
and that's it so representative partial
you can ask it thank you so much for
your indulgence chair
um
do i understand that now we're looking
at a situation like nelson again our
favorite town here
and um
would you consider it economically
feasible to install a 4g lte system in
that town if it serves the needs
without uh being as robust as a 5g
could you see something at an event like
that occurring
can you i'm sorry can you repeat
um
the uh statement that chair vote said
we're going to highest uh functionality
or what's the word um and
so that would imply that maybe we're
looking at a 5g situation for time like
nelson could you see any company coming
in saying we're going to wire nelson for
a 4g lte system or is that a thing of
the past
that opens up a whole different
discussion but um
you know
a t
has 5g here in new hampshire you know
and it's and it's not the
the small cell version um it's it's the
big cell it's the macro cell so when
when we come in
today and and put on a new tower um it
has to be you know contiguous with where
our 5g service is today but we will we
will build a 4g lte network and most
likely it will have
5g
already so we're not going to go into
nelson and say
you know this doesn't warrant 5g we're
just going to do 4g
and you know we're shutting off our 3g
as most everybody else is to make room
for the the next
iteration so that it really doesn't come
into play the network is the network
all right well thank you very much i
think we have exhausted our time for
this uh
public hearing
uh we're over by
almost 10 minutes we did start 15
minutes late so i've been a little bit
liberal and
adhering to our
schedule but i think we're going to call
it
a public hearing for now so i'm going to
close the public hearing on hb
395.
blue sheet information please from
representative nick williams
senate bill 395 seven in support one
opposed zero neutral open until midnight
tonight
thank you representative mick williams
so now
let's resume
the public hearing that i opened a few
minutes ago on house bill or senate bill
relative to renewable energy and natural
and i don't believe that
senator brad is here today to
introduce this bill even though he's the
prime sponsor but i think we have
a substitute
oh senator bradley is here
we're very fortunate
senator bradley welcome it's nice to
have you back in st e it's good to see
you sir
thank you very much
it's all yours senator okidoke thank you
mr chair and
members of the committee
um
pleased to be here for the record jeb
bradley from wolfeboro
and the sponsor of senate bill 424 which
um passed the senate
uh unanimously
maybe a month ago and obviously here we
are
so what this um seeks to do is allow a
utility to recover costs
if a utility procures um renewable
natural gas
and i think that given our energy
situation
where we're trying to get more and more
renewable sources of power
um this is a very good although very
small
step in the direction of allowing
the possibility of renewable natural gas
which would otherwise be emitted into
the environment
to be captured
purified so it meets the same standards
as conventional natural gas
and then be utilized as a replacement
for other natural gas in
the existing pipeline infrastructure
for natural gas in the state
so what can renewable natural gas come
from it could be animal waste it could
be food waste could be renewable gas
from landfills could be low low-grade
wood
and other sources
it is intended to be a substitute for
natural gas
and
it will have i think a number of
positive benefits both in terms of jobs
but also as i said
renewable energy and also
and i think this is
uh pretty important from
an environmental point of view
capturing methane emissions methane
being one of the
um
principal gases and one of the most
damaging
of those in terms
of global warming
so let me
where's my copy of the bill
try to walk you through the provisions
of the bill
here we go sorry
so in the legislative findings it talks
about you know the merits of it
obviously which i um
discussed
so i want to
call out what's on line 16.
this is something that's not mandatory
for the public utilities commission to
approve
recovery of prudently incurred costs the
word may
which is very important
for the commission to be able to
determine the public interest
may approve recovery
of those costs
then
it creates a new chapter with
definitions for biogas gasification
carbon offsets
etc etc
i'll skip ahead to
what are known as the incremental costs
on line nine of the bill
it talks about avoidance of conventional
gas purchase or development such as
avoided pipeline costs or carbon
emission reduction costs through the
avoidance of capacity costs so these are
sort of the price points
and how the public utilities commission
it would be intended that
they would um
judge the public interest the standard
for
approving whether a utility can go
forward with
this type of scenario
jumping down to line 30 on page two
again it says
very clearly the commission may approve
upon a filing of a petition by a gas
utility recovery of costs
including the use
of an associated cost recovery mechanism
but only
if it's in the public interest and again
the public interest has to take in to
affect things like the environmental
impact
the energy reliability the cost to
consumers all of those things have to be
adjudicated
by the public utilities commission
important to note on the top of page
three how it outlines the monetary
benefits of the proposal to utility
customers as well as the environmental
attributes and carbon offsets all of
which
constitute what the public utilities
commission
would look at in terms of determining
the public interest
starting on line four
it
this was something that was added in the
senate process
that the proposal advances the
objectives of state energy policy
including consumer choice and improving
the gas system resiliency and
diversification
all things that
we should
at least in my opinion favor
also added in the process um
on line eight and nine
and ten is a competitive
um bidding process
um that has to be through consultation
with the department of energy in terms
of rfps
and then um
lastly
there is a five percent cap on a
utility's total gas volume so as i
started out in the beginning
this is meant to be
a pilot program but an ongoing pilot
program i think you will hear from the
utilities as the senate heard from the
utilities that this is
um not only an emerging technology but a
viable technology and something that
should be workable so happy to mr chair
answer any of your questions
thank you senator questions for the
senator representative samsich
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
um
do you do you see this bill as
a viable um
option to
replacing the need for extra natural gas
to be imported into the state
and would would it be competitive enough
financially
to compete with that well first of all
representative uh thank you for your
sponsorship of the bill i appreciate
that very much
um
you know i think those are questions
that get answered through the process i
mean at a five percent cap
um
we
a get an opportunity to determine what
the supply is what the cost is what the
infrastructure
is needed to
um
you know be able to produce this
and then you know assess it based on its
carbon offsets especially if the
bill uses methane so
i don't know that we can answer those
questions today but i do
think that um
this is definitely technology worth
exploring it's the time is now to do it
and i think it could lead in those
directions if there's adequate supply
and the cost is reasonable the only way
we'll find out is taking this step
it's okay
uh representative miggy has a question
yes thank you mr chair i'm not a
co-sponsor
what does that mean you can ask me
questions if co-sponsors can't
well we we usually limit yeah anyhow
that's that's up to the chair
um
my question is around you mentioned
as you started your testimony that it's
just a small amount of gas necessarily
and i think the concern that i had in
reading through the bill is that we are
setting it up so that there's a rate
payer
reimbursement
to
gas
companies for procuring their gas from
these sites
and yet there doesn't seem to be
anything written in here in terms of
any types of
specificity around offsets or the
expectation that this we're calling it
renewable but do we have any idea if if
these sites are already emitting methane
how much how much we're going to
actually be
sequestering or capturing or using and
um and whether it's actually going to be
that benefit that we're saying it is
well again and and i have to
you know give a shout out to
my friend from portsmouth
who's not a co-sponsor of the bill but
you're not going to be able to ask me a
question about the red sox getting
shellac two out of three times that's
what this card is about
by the yankees
representative pitz's favorite team so
to get back to your question i think
again is
uh the question for representative
sosmich that's what um
you know a pilot program at five percent
i think helps answer those questions
especially in terms of you know the
methane
um
that could come from animal waste or
from landfills that that
is an ongoing situation but if it can be
utilized and utilized in a cost
effective and environmentally acceptable
way i think that
is helpful i agree i agree but i think
my my concern or my question is there's
nothing
specific in the bill about the level of
accountability that's required or the
level of emissions reductions that would
be required to make it a benefit and you
i think what you're saying is
we're going to go in by defining the
fact that the rate payers will be
helping with whatever infrastructure is
required in order to create a site that
would that would function but we're not
requiring at the same time or trying to
define
what kind of benefit we will be getting
from the site or in order to make those
investments i would partially agree with
you and partially disagree with you
there's no specificity in terms of the
um
amount of offsets but at the same time
the fact that offsets are referred to
and that there has to be a public
interest determination which means
net benefits of
cost environmental reliability
those things that the public utilities
commission
takes into account i think that you can
make a pretty clear argument
if
you are just arguing on an environmental
ground when a utility makes a filing
before the public utilities commission
or
environmental groups which intervene at
the commission
that
in order to meet the public interest
standard there has to be that you know
level of
um offsets without the bill
taking a hard and fast position that
might undermine
the opportunity to go forward with this
because again
sometimes we don't know we don't know
and that's why it's small to start with
okay okay representative mirner is
recognized for a question thank you
senator bradley um about a year and a
half ago a company i think they're out
of france
was looking at a low-grade wood gas
plant in the north country it's been an
ongoing discussion with business and
economic affairs
now they're using two sites you're
looking at one in vermont over the
border but it's my point is any of this
would this benefit that project that
kind of fell through up there right now
that's on hold it could i mean obviously
biomass is cited from the bill the
technology is emerging as i understand
it correct so it could be helpful
it would have to depend on
you know proximity to pipelines and
things like that to make it economical
but it's certainly a possibility
okay further questions for the senator
uh could you hold it for someone else we
have six other people who would like to
testify on this bill bill
so senator bradley i know you're very
busy we'll we really thank you for being
here to introduce the bill but let you
go so you can get on to other things
and we'll see you again tomorrow
to talk about senate bill 271
maybe the red sox will win tonight and
the yankees will lose and then we'll be
tied
let's hope so
all right next i'd like to hear from the
department of energy and griffin robarge
thank you chairman vos members of the
committee for the record griffin roberge
new hampshire department of energy um
department is neutral on senate bill 424
just by way of background the department
did work with senator bradley an
interested stakeholders in the senate on
an amendment that addressed all the
department's technical concerns uh with
the bill's language
so
we don't have any at this time uh any we
don't have any technical concerns with
the bill so
really with that uh they'll conclude my
testimony and i'll certainly answer any
questions anybody might have
could you speak briefly about the fiscal
note did you and the rest of the
department have anything to do with the
construction of the fiscal note yes uh
we did um construct the fiscal note um i
believe committee members should have
the fiscal note as amended by the senate
so it was amended
3 7 22
[Music]
obviously as senator bradley alluded to
the bill authorizes the recovery of
costs related to utilities procurement
of natural gas upon approval by the puc
there is language in the bill
specifically on page three of the bill
lines eight
and lines fourteen
um requires the
department to review all the requests
for a
request for proposals for renewable
natural gas supply
and on line 14
again because it's kind of a pilot
program
the department of energy in consultation
with the gas utilities will study each
utility's renewable natural gas
contracts
um
oh i apologize where i'm i'm looking
specifically on page three of the bill
line 14 i'm
sorry page three line 14. so um the
department of energy is required to
study each utilities renewable natural
gas contracts if they do obviously enter
into those contracts um the study shall
begin three years of the effective date
the study includes various factors such
as market terms price conditions
economic benefits etc etc
the department
shall generate that report deliver its
findings to the speaker senate president
house clerk senate clerk puc
um and the cost of the study would be
funded by a special assessment um on the
utility and utilities purchasing this
rng
um the department estimates that the
study will cost roughly 25 thousand
dollars due uh to complete due to the
need for outside consultants and
analysts
um again that cost would be covered by
special assessment on the natural gas
utilities that elect to procure rng
um
aside from that um
i'm referencing the fiscal note here now
i'm sorry um aside from the recovery of
the cost of the study
the department does not
expect any impact on state county or
local revenue
you know that might change due to
whether or not a state county or union
of local government is a customer of you
of a gas utility and elects to purchase
rng
um
but that's essentially
it um certainly willing to answer any
questions thank you questions for uh
representative harrington is
recognized thank you mr chairman i think
you're taking my question i guess um
my first position my first question
would be uh was anyone from the puc do
you know if they were involved in this
bill at all and if they have an opinion
on it one way or the other i i can't
speak to that um i don't know i don't
know
off the top now follow follow up
uh it appears what's being done here is
that the puc will have some adjudicative
process and will decide yes or no and
allow the uh utility to go out and
procure this uh renewable natural gas
then in the future the department of
energy is going to be reviewing that and
making some determination of how whether
the whether it's working
so and that goes back to the puc
but basically they already said they
thought it was a good idea so this is
like a
a post review that they'll be doing and
advising the puc on it
thank you for the question represent i
guess i wouldn't say it's necessarily
well the report as outlined on page 14
would go to the puc but obviously
because this is a new concept i believe
the intent here and i certainly don't
want to speak for the sponsor uh but i'm
going to
so um is maybe to inform policymakers
such as yourselves as to how this
program is working uh um and everything
like that to the extent that gas
utilities do want to petition the puc
for recovery of these costs i just it's
the first time that i'm aware of that
we're having one department review
another department's work and say what
you did was either good or bad yeah i
mean it's kind of unique yeah and i
don't think it's it's i don't think the
report is necessarily saying this is a
good thing or a bad thing i think it's
just more of an inclusive study looking
at various factors related to this type
of pilot program
and obviously that report would be
generated and delivered to legislators
the governor puc to review and things
like that all right thank you thank you
additional questions representative
mcgee has a question
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
robert for taking my question
um in looking at the language that you
referred to that starts on 14 and then
goes on
let's see
sentence that starts on 16 says the
study shall include but not be limited
to market term price conditions
availability service quality economic
benefits
and it goes on
the thing that i'm concerned about is
that
up until this point
renewables uh referred to
um
non-emitting sources that we could use
to procure energy and they were in a you
know separate category and
and now we're using the word renewable
for
natural gas
um
to elicit them
to to elicit that
source from a new it's a new source but
just like a fracked well i mean
it's a limited amount of gas that can be
secured and procured and sold yes
so it's it's not dissimilar it's just a
different source
and so my question is
this list does not include again
anything about the environment which is
the kind of point of having the
renewable source that puts it in a
different category so i'm concerned that
we're
we're using this terminology to talk
about gas that continues to emit
without listing
what what i would think would be a
primary um
primary point that we would want to be
assessing which is whether or not there
is an environmental benefit to securing
the gas in this way
that that's really my question is
there's nothing in here saying that
you're going to be looking over
how well anybody that's going to be
procuring this gas for their own benefit
with rate payers paying for the
infrastructure
whether or not
there's an environmental aspect here
that is going to be looked at by the
department or department of
environmental services or anyone
the fact that it's not listed i think is
seems like a real oversight with a
project like this
sure sure and thank you very much for
the question representative you know i
again
much of what the department did in the
senate was just addressed technical
concerns with the bill we weren't
necessarily in the position of
advocating uh you know
specific directions of the bill or
anything like that just to make sure
that if this bill were to move forward
that it operated appropriately i think
if you know to the extent policy makers
want to have a specific study looking at
environmental impacts obviously that's a
call for uh this committee to make and
obviously if that's something um that
you want to ask more about i encourage
you to reach out to the the bill's
sponsors or the uh follow-ups
stakeholders
yes i think
sort of what i'm getting at is that
we're
taking a terminology and we're applying
it here to this new type of project
right renewable
renewables are in a category because of
a benefit that they provide
and i'm not sure that this type of a
project
it's like a slippery slope where we're
taking um
a terminology and applying it here
which may in turn allow you know provide
other benefits going down
into the future
to this form of sequestration of gas so
that's what i'm trying to figure out is
where does the term come from is it
because these landfill sites are
constantly emitting methane
that we're calling them renewable
because it's it's an ongoing source
sure and thank you again for the
question again that's not necessarily
something i guess i'm in a position to
comment on the department didn't you
know provide technical feedback to the
bill we didn't write the bill so again
probably a question to maybe direct to
uh interested stakeholders or um the
prime sponsor okay thank you that's okay
representative bernardi is recognized
for a question
thank you mr chairman uh
and uh thank you mr robert uh what
renewable gas capacity do you see
coming from this uh
venture in new hampshire well
thank you for the question
representative bernardi i know there is
um
an ongoing docket at the puc that is
suspended for the time being um i
believe in that
docket and forgive me i'm doing this
from memory is that
a gas utility petitioned the puc because
they wanted to
work with a company called
rude arpa i think which is a resource
recovery company that was going to
capture a lot of the methane that's
released from a landfill in the north
country i believe that's
bethlehem yeah
i'm sorry
representative murder do you have an
answer yes one of our buildings actually
i think it was uh 577 or a few years ago
we attached the gas on the bottom of
that bill and it was specific to
bethlehem that company so it was on a
bill that
did was made topic was actually
berlin
okay representative bernardi continue
with your question i'm sorry um and so i
believe that docket's ongoing so i
believe there is um certainly interest
from companies out there to capture
some of this methane or other means
that's outlined i think in
page 2 lines 22-27
to the extent that it
if you're asking me to guess how much
there may or may not be out there i
couldn't necessarily answer but there is
kind of a cap in the bill um with a five
percent cap as outlined on page three
line 11 so you know just kind of a a
narrowly tailored pilot i guess you
could say in a way
let's move on now
we have other folks who need to testify
on this bill thank you
i appreciate that uh from the department
of energy and i'd like to call now on
cat fork from unitil a gas company she
ought to have some answers for us
please turn on the mic
is it on now
i didn't know griffin shut me off
um
for the record my name is kat burke and
i'm the director of government affairs
at unitil
unitil is here today in support of this
piece of legislation and i do think most
of the
highlights of the bill have been well
covered by senator bradley but
if you would like to indulge me in more
than the one minute i wrote on my
testimony card i'm happy to walk through
sort of how unitil sees this process
unfolding i know it can be a little bit
confusing especially given the
significant changes that we saw in the
senate
so essentially um
what would happen is a utility would
have a gas utility so liberty or unitil
would have an interest in going out and
procuring renewable natural gas and
partaking in a contract for renewable
natural gas when we do that we would
have to issue under the amended version
of the senate
various rfps in consultation with the
department of energy so that would be
strictly in consultation and that would
be exactly what we would do even if this
wasn't in the bill right we would of
course go to the department we would
work closely with the individuals that
we worked with during this stakeholder
process you know tom franz david shulock
et cetera
to discuss what these contracts tracks
are looking like their price um duration
which has a hard cap of 15 years in this
bill etc after we worked on that with
doe again it wouldn't require approval
from the department but it would require
um you know extensive conversation with
them we would then decide whether or not
we wanted to move forward with a formal
filing with the commission which would
then have to sort of walk through this
multi-prong public interest test that
you see in the amended version of the
senate on the bottom of page two
and on the top of page three
subsections a and b
so it would be the burden of the utility
to
prove that the monetary benefits of the
proposal to utility customers and the
state are there
including the value of any environmental
attributes or carbon offsets which are
both defined in this bill we would also
weigh whether or not the proposal in
front of the commission advances the
objectives of the state's
tenure energy strategy in the energy
policy of the state under rsa 378
that would include enhancing consumer
choice improving gas system resiliency
through diversification of supply etc so
those would be all things that we would
present to the commission when and if
after consultation with the department
we decided to move forward with this
after that the public
the public interest standard laid out
here the commission would walk through
that and decide whether or not
the utility meets those standards right
just like they do with any other
balancing test or test put forth in
statute
if and when any of the utilities were to
take part in this
three years after the effective date of
this bill there would be a comprehensive
study that the doe would kick off in
consultation with the utilities that you
know like rep mcgee said he would study
all of these particular issues economic
benefits whether or not the market has
developed what the price of rng is
compared to say conventional natural gas
et cetera
service quality
any sort of benefits to participating
customers or non-participating customers
and to be clear in order to change that
five percent cap
we would need to come back to the
legislature so that study i'm imagining
would probably recommend something like
that either it makes sense to keep it at
this let's raise the cap let's get rid
of this let's anything right
and then we'd have to come forward with
another piece of legislation so the
guardrails in place here are the
consultation with doe when we're putting
out the rfps the public interest test
that's at the commission
and then the study that will follow in
three years
um or about thereafter
so unitil feels as though you know all
the stakeholders who've worked on this
bill have really um worked hard to
develop significant control mechanisms
for for ratepayers um while recognizing
that rng is you know a developing
technology that has a lot of
environmental benefits including but not
limited to potentially being carbon
neutral in that when you capture it and
use it as a source you're capturing and
utilizing
more methane than what would be emitted
into the air if you were just letting it
emit into the air right
so we see a lot of benefits here and we
think that this is you know the right
pace and magnitude for a state of like
new hampshire to move forward with this
many other states are
putting in rng bills like this at 20 or
30 percent minimum so 5
with a 15-year cap on contracts a study
are all really good
places to start here and i'm happy to
take any questions
thank you that was an excellent
overview of how the process would work
i notice in the bill that on page 2 line
there is a definition of renewable
energy that includes biomass
and i'm wondering
if biomass is renewable is renewable
natural gas also
renewable in that sense and is there any
difference between the two
yeah i mean i know um we work closely
with the rng coalition who i don't
believe is here today but i do believe
you got testimony from them submitted um
but rng is the
term used by the industry it's you know
renewable natural gas i have no other
you know insight outside of that but i
do know that rng can be derived from or
has been derived from all of the sources
outlined here
um this is a sector neutral and source
neutral bill right so you know as
senator bradley said if
we find here in the state that there's a
lot of local resources from landfills or
the biomass industry from you know woody
byproduct anything like that animal
waste etc
that's certainly something we can use i
know we've seen companies like hannaford
and maine looking to contract
to use their
produce that you or i may not buy at the
store because it's bruised old et cetera
put that into a digester and be able to
hopefully make something like rng out of
this so it's
quite literally something that would
otherwise go to waste but i would
consider that renewable energy to mean
renewable under that definition of the
bill
representative mcgee has a question
thank you mr chairman and thank you ms
book for taking my question it's very
informative um i my question is around
the
chemical plant that will be needed at
any landfill i'm curious since you're
with unitil
if you could discuss in other places
where they've already had projects like
this what kind of a chemical plant would
be required
yes or infrastructure i guess not very
um involved in that side of the process
of course um you know and under the bill
actually we really couldn't be involved
in that process
the senate did amend the piece of
legislation to insist that the utilities
cannot be involved in the rng
infrastructure so we can't rate base
that which makes a lot of sense right so
these would be private organizations
private businesses who are billing
building
die gestures
and um utilizing you know putting up
capital utilizing that process that i am
only broadly familiar with very high
level
follow-up
follow up so i guess the only other
question i would have then is
are there are there additional pipes
involved in order to get it where it
needs to go do you have any idea of how
that part yes
so under this particular version of the
bill
i believe we would be able only to
invest in infrastructure that would
include dropping it in the pipe
transporting it we wouldn't we would not
but you can truck it
depending on where
that private company was located if it
was very close to a liberty or unitil
pipe that you could drop it in that
would certainly be ideal right
but part of the
issue here in new hampshire is we have a
real interesting i call it the chicken
and the egg problem right we want to
develop this rng market we want to see
private businesses
you know contract
for rng with the utilities but up until
now this wouldn't be possible unless
this you know bill moves forward right
so we're hoping to see um more
development in the market
once this once this happens but that
would be something that would be
included in that study that i mentioned
earlier as well okay thank you sure okay
representative callie pitts you get the
last question for ms burke
okay
um
thank you for taking the question
my question would be where then would
the rate pay is having to foot some of
the bill come in if it's not with the
infrastructure would it be at the in the
uh
payment agreements
so uh
sorry that's it thank you thank you for
the question representative um i think
the the issue that some individuals have
raised with the cost to rate pairs is
regarding the cost of rng itself
compared to conventional natural gas
that unitil or liberty is delivering now
historically speaking rng has been
slightly more expensive than
conventional natural gas however
i think we can all agree that right now
the cost of natural gas is very high so
this bill if it were to move forward
would allow the utilities to utilize rng
as a drop-in replacement for natural gas
including at times like now where the
cost of natural gas is high
there could be a time when the market
further develops in the future where rng
is at cost or less expensive than
natural gas
and that of course would be a great
benefit for the state right but that
would be the the time um when it's
incurred
follow-up
follow-up quickly would be then you
would if you contracted with these
companies you would contract them with
them for a certain period of time
and you would take that gas no matter
what it costs is that correct
no so well we would have to issue the
rfps it would have to be less than 15
years for the contract unless the
department of energy thinks it should be
something other than that
and then again remember we would still
have to go to the commission and prove
that this rng is in the public interest
with the prongs in the test laid out
here and then the commission could say
yay or nay so they could say no you
can't move forward with this contract
it's pre-approval so you you can't um
contract for this rng
no
so so that process is pretty well laid
out here so the cost will not be
incurred to rate payers unless it's
approved by the puc at the cost that we
present to them
okay ms bork we appreciate that
testimony thank you we're going to move
on we still have quite a few people who
want to testify and unfortunately
because we're running short i'm going to
have to start limiting people to
two minutes
of testimony so next we'll hear from
katherine corcory of the new hampshire
sierra club
welcome back
um
i'll give you three minutes oh that's
plenty um i handed out some testimony
in
here um
i think it's the last
yeah
this being the science and technology
committee i wanted to make sure you got
some good science
and this last report
um is from it looks like this one it's
from the air resources council of
california
and it talks about
emissions from landfills
and contrary to what we just heard
it
it's not what it seems
my name's catherine corkery i'm from new
hampshire sierra club
uh i'm the chapter director uh sorry i
didn't do that
first uh if you go to um it's it's a
really
um
short report
um but i wanted to
highlight
page five in that section combining the
two effects
here
and this this report talks about
closed landfills and active landfills
and the different types of
the rate of emissions
and the thing is
in a landfill that has been capped
or even an active landfill
the emissions percolate
and
they emit all over the landfill not just
the one pipe that they have that they
flare off right and it emits all over
and what they have found
is that when they add all the equipment
to help make this
this methane gas
usable
to put into a pipeline you have to
really pump it up
and when that happens you're pumping up
the whole landfill
not just
the
methane that gets put into the pipe
and so what happens overall
you're actually emitting more escape gas
and that's that 3.8
to 7.8 times more
greenhouse gases
when you have this augmentation of a
landfill
and i really i
i
so want i want this to work
but it just doesn't work like that i
feel like um
that ad about
putting things online on on facebook or
something like it just it doesn't work
like that
the emissions when you're pumping up the
emissions to go out
you're not capturing all of it and in
fact
there's more escaped emissions
overall
and so you're making matters worse
for climate
um
so there's that report 30 seconds oh my
goodness
i had three
i had three points um point number one
the emissions uh
are are not what they seem number two it
was about ratepayers rate payers
ratepayers ratepayers are paying for
this
um i'm i'm really surprised that
this is something
that this kind of project would be
paid by rate payers but something that
would actually save ratepayers money
like new hampshire saves was was not a
not supported by this third point and
the third point thank you for that
um was about changing
the
moving the goal posts
um there is as we heard a docket at the
puc that is active now
and um in that docket
there was a
an issue
and the petitioner asked
that the docket be suspended
um so that then they could come here
and fix
change something change the law
and they would go back to the puc now
they said they also said
that they would still move forward on
their docket at the puc
if this bill fails
but
i as someone who was here for northern
pass i heard time and time again
that we could not change
anything about the site evaluation
committee
in regards to the northern pass because
it was an active docket
and i'm i'm just um
i i feel like this could
change the precedence
at the puc and i think that's dangerous
so please
oh
sorry please oppose this bill thank you
okay
good try you were about two minutes over
but that's okay
so
would it surprise you to learn that
methane which is reported in parts per
billion in the atmosphere
versus carbon dioxide which is reported
in parts per million
to put it in perspective the amount of
methane that's in the air
if it was
uh
computed as feet
on the on the highway between new york
city and los angeles
would be 26 feet
i wouldn't be surprised
that is the case
all right uh further questions for ms
corkery
representative samsich
thank you mr chairman thank you miss
corkery um
so
uh
if in fact
what you say is true that this would
create more greenhouse gas emissions
from methane
uh then would be recoverable or compared
to flaring
uh do you see other ways of recovering
that methane
from landfills that would not do such
great harm
i think um
thank you for the question because
that's
there are really two issues at hand one
is a waste issue and one is an emissions
issue and and what would be great is if
we did not
send
this organic matter to landfills
like
what we have here if there is um
another
because organic matter is really great
for soil
and making compost
and um i don't know about you but my
backyard is nothing but sand and having
really good compost is really important
um
that would be a really great solution
to
finding a new place for this kind of
organic matter
um
so
follow up
yeah i understand that but what i'm
saying is um we have these landfills now
they are there okay so i don't disagree
with you we shouldn't be doing it this
way
but these landfills are already there
uh
uh no one's come up with an idea of how
to dismantle them or convert them to
something else so do you see any way
that we could possibly recover methane
from
these
closed landfills
in an environmentally
sound way so that we don't do more harm
than good
right and i think um there
you know there's this study
um unfortunately it's at the tail end
i would flip that over and put the study
at the beginning we heard from
two speakers here that this is new
technology
that maybe there should be a thorough
study first
and then
look into this rfp process and maybe
clear it up because it wasn't clear to
me
that this was some sort of plot pilot
program
from this bill
but certainly what lebanon is doing
um the city of lebanon has
just
instead of
um piping out the gas or trucking out
the gas which is the proposal at the puc
this what they're doing in lebanon is
that they have a generator right there
and they're putting it into the wires
the electricity directly into the wires
that's certainly a lot more cost
efficient for rate payers
um okay that's uh
that's a little bit off subject for the
bill but we appreciate that sure we're
going to move on because we still have a
lot of people to testify and i'm going
to call next on kelly buchanan of clean
energy new hampshire who supports the
bill
and has written testimony for us thank
you ms buchanan of course thank you mr
chair and members of the committee i
will be exceedingly brief seeing as we
are short on time
but for the record my name is kelly
buchanan i'm the director of legislative
and regulatory affairs at clean energy
new hampshire and we are in support of
senate bill 424
and its potential to capture sources of
methane from existing waste streams
so in our interview locally produced
energy is one of the most important
tools to enable the diversified energy
landscape that caters to our energy
independence a lower cost of energy and
local economic development
uh senate bill 420 beam time really
um so while we believe that renewable
natural gas isn't quite as
sunny in terms of outlook and other
distributed energy resources like solar
hydro or wind
it is a potential near-term solution to
reducing our reliance on natural gas
especially as we've seen some of the
highest prices and
increasing instability in that market
so i'll be glad to take any questions
that you may have for me today but
otherwise that concludes my testimony
thank you i sincerely regret that
representative platt wasn't here to hear
you talk about the sunny outlook
[Laughter]
for uh renewable energy okay questions
for
ms buchanan
representative callie pitts
question that wasn't answered the last
time do you have any uh information on
new on unh study
what the reduction or the spread of
methane gas is or anything like that
just
is is it available and do you have it
i do not have it off the top of my head
but i would be happy to look into that
for you
ms buchanan thank you for being here
thank you i'll now call on john tuthill
who would like to oppose the bill and mr
tuthill i'll give you two minutes thank
you mr chairman members of the committee
this is a bill i really would have liked
to have supported and
i'm john tuthill from akwas new
hampshire sullivan county former member
of the ena
and i was glad that uh the senate had
made the amendments they made i think
that improves the bill but i don't think
we're ready for this yet particularly
looking at senate bill 367
in conjunction with 424
that one is over at ena right now
uh these two bills need to be looked at
together my main focus over the last
decades has been on on solid waste
policy
uh and landfills but um
in the case of this bill while landfills
are important and an important component
of development of of rng as a
resource in the state for energy
production
the ones that i think we really need to
be
careful about
are some of these other emerging
technologies modern pyrolysis
gasification chemical recycling
all of these have got the potential for
generating
a marketable product syn gas for example
by other bio gases and there are
contamination issues related to all of
this production when you're using
waste products as your feed stock so
i really think this bill needs to go to
study i think that des needs to be more
involved
in this particular bill in 424 i'm very
glad to see some consideration of the
public interest or what in des world is
called public benefit
but i think that that consideration does
need to con include
some thought about climate impacts
air pollution water pollution potential
which have in the past
and including at turnkey in rochester
have been associated with
some of the gas collection 30 seconds
thank you some of the gas collection
systems i'll leave it right there i did
submit a brief note
uh to members of the committee just
before i came down
but i do hope that you will consider
sending this to study along with 367
work on them together
and bring in the environmental
side of this question thank you
thank you 367 is a waste
uh a landfill bill that's correct well
not necessarily no it's more a
technology bill in my opinion this bill
could be considered more of a landfill
bill 367 they call it advanced recycling
i call it chemical recycling
um
it is actually mentioned if you look at
some of the definitions in the bill here
um
this is not just about landfills this is
about a number of different technologies
great thank you any further questions
for mr tuthill representative partial
thank you sir votes
um
as you are
uh
admittedly uh somewhat knowledgeable on
landfills
um
we are going to be looking down the line
at the public good on this bill um
but my concern is there's no baseline to
know i mean if if what our current
situation is when it comes to methane
production
methane off gassing on our current
landfills
so it could be comparing
two years down the line
the potential increase or decrease this
increase or decrease in methane
production
to uh numbers that we don't currently
have are you concerned about not having
a baseline established before you
proceed with this technology
thank you for the question that
certainly be one of the things i think
could be looked at for studying but
realize that
waste management's very large landfill a
regional landfill in rochester is
already
collecting
considerable amounts of methane and it
is being used for energy at the unh
campus so that's been going on for years
um
in bethlehem
unfortunately they the company
operating that landfill owns that
landfill decided not to
be capturing methane for energy
production but they have been flaring it
so the only area that really is emitting
direct methane is is the open face the
uncapped areas
so methane
is a serious issue i think as the
chairman has pointed out however
landfills are only a piece of that
problem if you look at this globally and
in terms of climate um you want to be
thinking a lot more just about how do we
start reducing
uh greenhouse gases in in our entire
system through human activities
uh landfills are at the waste sector it
has been estimated is roughly seven
percent
or some of some are found in studies
it's about seven percent of our
contribution to man-made greenhouse
gases but that's the entire waste
system transportation
disposal uh processing
so it's significant
okay thank you mr tuttle we appreciate
it we have three more people who want to
testify but before we let them do that
i will
open the public hearing on
senate bill 429 fn
which is relative to the site evaluation
committee and i will recess that
public hearing until we finish this one
is that all right with you
representative guida thank you
okay so next person to testify will be
nick krakoff of the conservative
uh conservation law foundation
and i'm going to give you two minutes
how's that
that's fine thank you thank you i'm
honorable committee members my name is
nick krakow i'm with the conservation
law foundation
um so today we talked a lot about guard
rails with with uh sb424
and frankly there just aren't enough
guardrails with this bill to ensure that
it's in the public interest
that's why clf is proposing a number of
amendments i provided written comments
by email to the members of the committee
so you'll see those amendments outlined
in more detail there but i'm going to
talk about them briefly right now
in general rng cost significantly more
than traditional natural gas
several people talked about this
proposal before the puc
there uh there were several analyses
done on that proposal they found that
rng costs three times more
than um the traditional natural gas so
this is a burden to rate payers
um you know maybe someday it'll be
cheaper than traditional natural gas but
we're not there yet so we need guard
rails in place to make sure this isn't
going to burden rate payers too
extensively
and so the bill doesn't have those guard
rails in place
looking at the um
the discussion of sort of the greenhouse
gas emissions benefits
um
you know that language doesn't provide
enough protections in place to ensure
that this bill is in the public interest
for example the language there does not
um properly account for methane leakage
from remove from rng
that language needs to be strengthened
to ensure that it properly accounts for
that leakage as well as for the
transportation emissions involved with
transporting the gas from
landfills
to distribution networks
second you know as i was mentioned
earlier this this gas is often sourced
from landfills
now there's nothing in the bill to
ensure that this doesn't contribute to
building new landfills or expanding
existing landfills 30 seconds so for
those reasons c clf is proposing a
number of amendments those are outlined
in further detail in the written
comments which i already provided um i
encourage you to look at those comments
that provide a little more detail on
what we're thinking but i usually to
only
pass this bill if those amendments that
are in our written comments are
adopted
very good thank you very much are there
any questions from the committee about
those amendments or anything else
they're in your email
your legislative email i took a look at
them myself
uh and i have no questions anybody else
have questions see none
uh did you
start to raise your hand representative
breshney thank you uh
my question is to something you said
that
that rng is three times as much as
natural gas
if we're not doing this how do we know
that it's going to be three times as
much as rng thank you well i'm talking
about the particular proposal that was
before
the puc that was filed last year you
know their analyses done by the oca as
well as from the department of energy
they found that that particular proposal
would be three times more expensive per
deca therm for rate payers and i'm not
gonna say that's gonna be that expensive
all the time but for that particular
proposal
okay thank you thank you very much and
our last uh well now our next to last
our pent ultimate testifier on this bill
will be jason stock from the timberland
owners association
good afternoon uh for the record i'm
jason stock i'm the executive director
of the new hampshire timberland owners
association and uh i did not plan on
testifying today but given the
conversation and the debate i've got two
minutes gotcha
um
given the conversation it was all about
landfills i wanted to point out biomass
and biogas are very much a part of this
bill and
one of the things
that
you know it's an emerging as you heard
from a previous speaker an emerging
technology is looking at using
whole tree tips biomass as a potential
energy source and gasifying them
as you folks passed earlier this or as
the house passed i should say earliest
earlier this session house bill 105 that
is designed to look at emerging markets
for low-grade wood we see this bill as
kind of a almost a fit with that because
because energy markets this is a
potential fit with that bill because
this could pave the way for some of
those emerging markets that house bill
1005 is going to be looking at and
exploring to help address the low-grade
wood crisis that the forest products
industry is facing
and
to representative mcgee's concerns about
some of the renewable renewable aspects
of it when we look at biomass
gasification on page 1 line 27 that ties
specifically to the definition
when we talk about biomass that's used
in the rps that was a definition that
had been contemplated and looked at
embedded
in the context of what is quote
renewable biomass and so that that piece
from our point of view is
kind of
checks that box
and that again ties back into page two
line 24 where we talk of where it talks
about rng so that's kind of the
how this threads through and how this
connects to to wood chips forest
products and i would argue in conclusion
i would argue that when we look at
public good
and you're going to hear more about this
probably tomorrow when we look at public
good we look at biomass
we look at
look at the big picture look at our
forest look at the jobs that that are in
our forest products industry and how
this dovetails with the state's
rural economies
and
the health of our forest and our ability
to perform sustainable management you've
all heard it before this is this is also
a piece of it we look at it as a
potential emerging market
and i'd be happy to try and answer any
questions
two minutes 30 seconds pretty good
okay any questions for
representative samsuch has one
thank you mr chairman thank you mr stock
uh can you um
elaborate how you see
um the
um
the wood wood
industry and the um
wood products becoming a part of this
is that separate from the methane
portion now you're talking about yeah i
mean i i would say
that the nexus here is
let's say you have a sawmill that's
producing mill waste out the back end of
that mill
chipped slabs bark sawdust
there are emerging technologies now that
can take that
product or looking at taking that
product and gasifying it
um and producing a
either a liquid fuel or a what i would
call rng out of it if that let's say
that saw mill or that facility is
located in conjunction with an existing
gas line
there you go you can tap right into that
gas line and provide it
and so that's that's how we we view it
is there's another this creates some
opportunities for our industry down the
road
okay uh
representative callie pitts
jason uh thank you sure i
when i heard you say tree tips i think
you said tree tips or treetops whatever
we in this
state i believe pretty soon are going to
have a landfill crisis will we be
filling up our landfill with free tips
and bottoms and things that people don't
need right now um
is that contributory they i know they
biodegrade but they take a while to do
that
yeah they do i
mean
i don't i'd hate to see that day when we
take either chips from a sawmill or
sawdust from a sawmill
and or tree tips chipped wood
and just have to land fill it
again as an organization
we we believe this is a renewable
resource there are opportunities to
capture energy from it and
and even other products from it
house bill 1005 looks at that
this also creates an opportunity to try
to look at all right is rng one of those
pieces that can capture the value
it would be pretty sad to see that
renewable resource being dumped into a
landfill just because there's literally
no other home for it
and that's a good closing statement so
we appreciate your testimony uh thank
you mr stock
and our last speaker on this bill is
mark brown from the consumer energy
alliance who supports the bill
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is mark
brown i'm executive director of new
england for consumer energy alliance
and on behalf of caa i want to thank you
for the opportunity to speak today in
support of senate bill 424
senate bill 424 is a forward-looking
bill
it will help prepare new hampshire and
its gas utilities for what the future of
the natural gas distribution system
might look like
the bill is a prime example of how
thoughtful legislation can balance
competing public interests
the provisions in sb424 will result in a
cleaner natural gas system with lower
emissions and ancillary benefits like
cleaner waste water streams
it will also help to ensure reliability
of the gas system
and preserve consumer choice by
insulating new hampshire consumers from
actions taken by its neighboring states
as well as the federal government that
may limit access to natural gas
additionally the five percent cap and
puc doe review study will protect
consumers from any potential and
excessive rate hikes renewable natural
gas will play an important role in the
energy transition and we support it i'd
like to address the cost issue real
quick um
you know i think contracts for natural
gas are probably in the seven to eight
dollar an mmb2 range right now for you
know gas gas distribution utilities
and i know that in places like vermont
um you know you're getting contracts for
rng and the 11 to 12 dollar you know an
mbt range so it's not that far off
especially when you start looking at
what's going on with
you know winter peaking gas you know the
january price for natural gas averaged
twenty dollars mmbtu i think february is
about 14. you know you're looking at you
know the federal government
holding back on on leasing for oil and
gas you're looking at potential you know
methane fees
we've seen actions at ferc that are
taking into you know downstream
greenhouse gas emissions that may
increase the cost of and restrict the
supply of natural gas
what's going on in new york with
restricting natural gas pipelines
certainly in fact affects new england so
this is kind of a bill that you know a
lot of people should be behind it's good
you know
it has environmental benefits but it
also will ensure and help protect
against reliability of the system and
preserve consumer choice people will you
know be able to use gas stoves um they
won't be forced to convert to you know
to electric or something like that so
with that i'll take any questions
thank you for that testimony i have a
question
you mentioned the price
of gas today maybe seven or eight
dollars per unit
um
rng in vermont might be 11
and
in the middle of winter it might be 20 a
unit
is it possible that you could
manufacture this rng and store it
and then use it during the winter when
the the peak
price of gas is high to bring that cost
down
is it possible
i'm sure it's possible i don't know if
it's cost effective to do that and i
think that's the big that would be the
that would be the big question and i
i can't i just can't you would have to
know what's going to happen with the
price of gas down the road but we know
that you know in new england we are more
susceptible to volatile gas prices than
literally anywhere else in the country
you know the price at henry hub
might be four bucks
and it'll be 15 here so you know that's
you're not comparing apples to oranges
when you're looking at those two prices
additional questions for mr brown
seeing none i guess we're done so thank
you very much thank you and with that
we'll close the public hearing on senate
bill
424-fn
and we will resume
blue sheet representative mick williams
could you read us the blue sheet on 424
please
senate bill 424 29 signed in and support
16 in opposition zero neutral it's open
until midnight
thank you very much
and now
we will
resume the public hearing that i opened
15 minutes ago on senate bill 429 fn
relative to the site evaluation
committee and i would love to introduce
the bill's crime sponsor senator bob
gaida
good afternoon senator thank you mr
chairman members of the committee for
the record bob guida state senator
district 2
and prime sponsor of
senate bill 429 fn
this bill is a product one of several
out of committee that met over the
summer
to discuss
the site evaluation committee uh and in
fact that report i think i provided in a
prior bill
it's dated october 1 of 2021 final
report of the committee to study
necessary revisions for the site
evaluation committee
and if you don't have that report i'm
sure you could access it and uh it's
it's a very good primer as for where
we're going with this bill
this bill does a number of things and
that's again based out of the results of
that study first it modifies the sec to
allow for agency designees
one of the problems they have in the
existing language for the existing
statute is it requires the commissioners
all to be in the same room at the same
time basically which is virtually
impossible to get done so it greatly
slows any progress that the sec might
get done so it allows designees
it changes the quorum down to five
members
um and incorporates training
for members of the sec on
on statutes and procedures and so forth
requires a public notice an adequate
public notice of committee proceedings
uh pursuant to 91a
so that there is
adequate time given of notice and then
of course
enabling our citizens as well as
other stakeholders to participate
by arranging their schedules timely
updates fees to reflect changes
changes previously applied by the fiscal
committee
clarifies certain that subsequent
certificate holders are responsible for
associated costs of their applications
and authorizes the committee
to impose a fine for preliminary
determinations of violations of anything
under 162h
also provides for funding all of the
operating funding of all operating costs
out of this sec committee fund
and allows the chair of the committee to
seek additional funding the sec funding
i think as i discussed in the previous
bill is sporadic because applications
aren't constant and they
sometimes they'll go two three years
without and sometimes you'll have two or
three in one year so that that doesn't
bode well for trying to maintain a
stable
um and funded staff without tapping
general fund revenues so take a look at
that
that pretty much sums up what the bill
gets proposes and
i would note that
senator i'm sorry representative um
votes representative harrington
uh also served on this committee in this
past summer and our co-sponsors on this
legislation
with that i'll conclude my testimony
take any questions
uh thank you senator gardner
excellent testimony a question from
representative
mcgee
thank you mr acting chairman and thank
you senator gaida um
i'm looking on page two
and down in the bolded area that starts
on line 19 and i wonder if you could
speak to us about
the various pricing structures that are
being applied to the various types of
energy
and how they were arrived at
i will leave that to subsequent
testimony okay thank you um were you any
part of that conversation and
did this come out of the subcommittee i
guess no this came out out of the
committee um but um
i think that those numbers were adjusted
to an attempt to cover the sporadic
nature of
maintaining a staff
to do that with the things that are
required that my recollection but yes oh
i think it's representing mcgee yes may
i
one last follow-up yes thank you
uh
i think
it is wholly appropriate for us to be
doing that because they clearly don't
have adequate funding i think there's a
distinction between
calling out all of the different types
and having them have widely different
numbers i i guess that's what i was
hoping you could speak to is how that
was arrived at because they're they're
not consistent with each other
all right
so sixty thousand dollar base charge
that's i believe that's for the
application
and then the twenty thousand for
monitoring and compliance remember we're
breaking where the department of energy
is gonna be most likely taken over
monitoring and compliance yes all right
so
i think that that would go towards that
i was i'm sorry it's my fault
on line 21 starts item number one and
one through five lists
various amounts
for different types of energy so i'm
wondering why
uh 1200 per megawatt for renewable
energy generating facility versus
120 per megawatt for a ga natural gas or
biomass fueled facility that's it's a
big jump so i'm just curious
uh unfortunately i'm not going to be
able to assuage your curiosity
okay
fair enough
uh additional questions representative
berezni
uh mine's not as much of a question i
just noticed all of these amounts are
increased by 20 percent is that
what you were asking
well they're all up 20
just across the board thank you for that
observation mr chairman if i might um
representative harrington i believe the
original numbers on here the thousand
one hundred hundred fifty and so forth
those were were done at the beginning of
the inception of the site evaluation
committee with the approximate cost
associated with prosecution because
obviously if you've got something that's
six hundred megawatts gas plant the per
megawatt cost is going to be different
than a 4 megawatt wind generator so and
then they just we just simply took that
and increased them because of inflation
so that's basically the basis for
representative mick williams is
recognized for a question
thank you senator for bringing this bill
um i just i guess i have a technical
question in regards to whenever we put
dollars right whenever we put dollar
amounts in a bill
we know we're going to be revisiting
this in 5 10 15 years and we're gonna
have to pass another bill
to change the numbers
so would you be open to an amendment
that does something related to a three
percent increase
so that we can try to track these
numbers without coming back again to the
well and
doing a basically bookkeeping bill again
at the house senate and the governor's
desk just to fix the numbers every
couple years
on that i thank you for the question i
think it's a valid question but i think
given the volatility of energy
and the changing structure of energy you
know and the changing structure of our
government as in the state here as we're
attempting to address this i'm not
certain that a steady state increase
would be appropriate i i would rather
actually leave it here and and require
the review periodically the legislature
uh to maintain uh you know
um frankly to maintain
oversight
over the fee structure
an average citizen cannot
go to the sec and want the fees change
but that's one of the problems that we
have is there an exorbitant price
for citizens on some uh and some of the
testimony that you wanted to bring in
some of the actions
so i would favor leaving it the way it
is rather than trying to incorporate
understandably to the to the
legislature's workload uh you know three
percent a year or something of that
nature i think volatility right now is
playing large i think we need to respect
that
thank you
senator did the sec study committee
find that these fees had not been
changed since 2015
i would probably say so yes thank you
thank you
any further questions for senator guida
representative callie pitts
senate guider if if a group of
individuals which you mentioned the fee
is exorbitant but my understanding is if
there's a problem with an application
and
that a group of individuals can petition
and have that application go to the sec
what would be the fee that that group of
individuals would have to pay
would it be in there at twelve thousand
dollars
no no i don't think it would be i think
it's significantly less yeah i
but i didn't see it and so it could be
an oversight on my part
i think if you look on page three
i gotta make sure i'm in the right area
here
a petition for declaratory ruling
um
up to twelve six or thirty six hundred
offered by a three-member subcommittee
and then if you go on to
uh request for i think that's
again
i'm not clear to be honest with you but
but the price was exorbitant for just an
average citizen to come up and address
the sec
a group of citizens could do so and you
want to make sure that we don't just
subject the process to what one might
call nuisance
complaints and what so we set the
threshold high enough that you have to
have a serious complaint or serious
request or serious idea
to be able to garner the attention of
calling the sec or three-member
subcommittee back together to address it
just to avoid nuisance complaints
amongst other things
may i follow up
yes please follow up but we don't know
how much that's going to be because most
citizens wouldn't have
you know
i'm thinking of an average citizen
myself for instance are they going to
put a wind farm in the back of my house
or do i have a right to go and say wait
a minute there's a problem
there's an application you've ruled on
it but
i i i want the sec
it's been approved but it hadn't gone
through the sec how much would it cost
because not beside the cost there would
probably be attorneys etc involved so is
this process
is there anywhere in this process that
we're redoing to make it
easier
for a group of citizens concerned
citizens to bring
their concerns or request the sec to get
involved in something that perhaps had a
declaratory judgment
again i i think that the concern is that
we would subject this especially
this process of citing an energy
facility which
historically has been
let's say less than cordial
uh
to
innumerable
uh complaints that were there intended
to delay obfuscate and so forth so
i don't think it's it's inappropriate to
establish a threshold
you know all any citizen can testify on
the siding
preparatory prior to the decision right
it's after the decision and one has to
make an assumption sometimes that does
you know what it does but nonetheless
that the sec is going to act in good
faith and do what's best
to challenge it after that
again i think that
to prevent nuisance complaints
uh you know if one citizen has a problem
is it really a problem if a community
has a problem and you have 20 citizens
that's a problem okay and so again the
point being to coalesce complaints
rather than to keep having one after
another after another on the basis of
independent citizens the way you do that
most effectively is to establish a
threshold that's not exorbitant but is
nonetheless uh responsible to prevent
the nuisance complaints
thank you senator
any additional questions for the senator
senator i would
remind the members of this committee
that your committee senate enr has house
bill 624
which is
under consideration there has been a
public uh hearing on that bill already
and
that bill provides
a way for the average citizen to file a
complaint against an existing
certificate
at no cost to the citizen isn't that
correct that is correct thank you
i hope the senate will move forward with
that bill we will
uh representative samsic
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
for taking my question uh and i'm sorry
i was
just out a minute here maybe this
question was already asked
but on
page two
uh lines um
25 regarding um
um application for elect generation
facilities for um
compliance charges
um
number one online 25 says
1200 dollars per megawatt
or a wind energy system
and then
line 30 says twelve hundred dollars per
penguin for a renewable energy
generation facility
the other items number two three and
four i'm i'm not certain i'm on the same
page
right
oh sorry are you looking at 429 fn as
amended
sorry i think i didn't
i had
but okay it's um similar so on page two
and that would be line 21
uh where it talks about twelve hundred
dollar per megawatt for a wind energy
system
and on line 26
it talks about 1200 dollars per megawatt
for a renewable energy facility
those two are
renewable energy facilities
and the charge for them per megawatt
is about 10 times higher than all the
other ones for natural gas for oil for
nuclear
why is that why is there such a big
discrepancy in the charge for
a wind energy and renewable facility
compared to
a natural gas a coal or
a nuclear generation
that's a very good question um is that
an oversight somehow or more typo
because that's quite a quite a leap
there
i don't have an answer for that i'm not
going to answer because i don't have an
answer okay and perhaps one of the
members of the committee can help
representative uh cambrils yes i think
if you read it it says
it looks like it's 10 times but it's not
because it's 120 per megawatt
versus
oh i'm sorry which which
i think it was the same question that uh
representative mcgee had is why it was
so why is such a discrepancy between the
different uh type of facilities
that goes back to the original
uh
site evaluation committee legislation
that was passed in 2014
so we'd have to consult with people who
were involved with that to understand
their reasoning for
representative mcgee on that point
before we move off it it it looks like
what's happened here i agree with
representative berezni that
items one through four
existed
and the increase was
right so the numbers were changed for
each of those
but number one related to
wind energy systems and i think it
probably came into being with northern
pass being considered and that sort of
thing wind projects that had gone in
front of
the sec but number five has been added
so that renewable energy facilities have
a 1200 per megawatt and i'm wondering
how that was arrived at like that's what
i'm curious about because
um some of the renewable energy facility
projects are quite simple and
straightforward and might not require
such a high
number and that that would be my
question
i just want to know where the if the
number came from the fact that
those renewable energy facilities were
going to be considered the same as the
wind facility
that
created number one
and if so why that expensive
just seems like it could be prohibitive
i i think it just drives to the point of
covering the costs
um
again this is an application fee
so
it's just discouraging of cleaner energy
right a megawatts megawatt so yeah
i don't think that was the
intent of the original legislation to
discourage renewable energy i think it
had to do with
the cost of evaluating an application
for a renewable energy system
but i'd have to go back and look at
the two 2014 legislation that
established those fees initially to
to discover exactly
why they were set at that level senator
bradley would know probably but he's not
here right now so we can't ask him
well maybe not state doesn't evaluate it
though all right it wouldn't be a
statement it's exciting it might not be
representative
one theory could be that um the
renewable energy projects are maybe less
megawatts on average than some of these
bigger ones and so in terms of how much
they get as a fee
would be a lot less for the renewable
ones versus the nuclear
that's likely the the answer yes
good point
all right further questions for senator
guida
seeing none i thank you senator
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee
okay
i didn't have one more pink card oh
there he is over in the corner form uh
mark's sanborn from the department of
environmental services i thought you'd
left the building but there you were
afternoon mark sanborn assistant
commissioner new hampshire department of
environmental services um testifying um
on in support of this bill
myself and bob scott
along with other members of the
executive branch participated in this
committee as well
we were here talking about another sec
bill last week
talking about phase one and phase two
we actually
just by
timing you guys did the bill that's
focused on phase two last week and this
is the one focused on phase one trying
to make some of the improvements so
um in the short term we improve the
functionality of the sec
um i will i too will not guess at the
answer but uh the actual perfect person
to know the reason where those numbers
originally came from is probably bob
scott himself i'll
i'll check in with bob and we'll get
back to you guys um any answer on where
those initial came from i can say
it was
um it did not have anything to do with
discouraging it it is about the cost and
um again if you remember when we
testified last week um unlike the other
regulatory activities of uh the state of
new hampshire this is a done by an ad
hoc committee with no staff
overseeing some of the you know looking
into these um complaints and issues
versus
um
other you know wetlands we haven't hold
up the agency so
they're it's just set up differently
which again goes back to the idea of
some short-term fixes to the sec with
the idea of a long-term fix being
putting these in an actual department so
they can
get the standard
regulatory response from the state
like the other regulatory issues
and i was going to address but uh
the chairman did as well um
the cost for com complaints i i think
the practice of the sec now is just is
to also take any complaints or concerns
from average citizens at no cost it's
the problem right now is there's no
staff
to
follow up on the complaints and even if
we had one administrator there's no
funds in the fund right now
to hire the necessary professional
technicians you would need to do the
testing
um to uh to evaluate the credibility of
the complaints so it's not so much that
because it costs the complaintants
funding it's that right now
there's no ability of anyone to follow
up on those complaints that's the real
problem again which this bill is i'm
trying to address in the short term
while we figure out a longer term
solution
so again just
like the other bill very supportive of
the sec
needs a lot of reform um and
with the energy infrastructure being so
important um on some bills i was
obviously here this morning
it's of high value to those of us who uh
help in the regulatory side of this to
continue to find ways to improve the
functionality of the sec
perfect thank you uh
questions representative samsic
thank you mr chairman thank you uh mr
sanborn um
in light of what you just said and we
all know this that the sec staffing and
the way they funded themselves
has created kind of a
non-functional entity
that
the fact that that is now going to be
part of the uh department of energy i
believe has its function
and i assume that you're gonna
provide enough staffing to have an
efficient program for this
and in light of the fact that we heard
all these projects and proposals this
morning which will impact that uh i
would think that you would need to look
review as well the funding and the fi
fees needed to support that uh because
it's going to be a different animal in
the future it should be yeah so um a
couple points to that number one i don't
want to
uh
pre-determine what will come out of the
study um i've mentioned as an individual
uh
my thought that doe moving this to the
oe makes sense but you know we're gonna
have a whole committee and then bring
that back to you um
those proposals would would most likely
come in hb2 where more full reform could
come including
funding um and so it would be packaged
in an ability to to have the legislation
be fully funded and um i have also
spoken
um to uh i'll i won't out them but some
myself and some of the other state
representatives and interested parties
i think in the short term what we would
probably do is if these bills along with
the chairman's and the two from senator
gaida pass
our big focus would be to
find an sec administrator um and then
probably go to fiscal committee asking
for a one-time infusion of funds to be
able to follow up on the existing
complaints
i i think is
we want to see how the legislation
passes and i want to talk to the
governor's office about that obviously
before moving forward but um i would
suggest that um finding an fcc
commissioner and having some amount of
funds in there to immediately start
following up on the backlog of
complaints is in everyone's best
interest
and then for the long term if if it was
decided
that
the right way to move forward is in hb2
putting a proposal together about um
these esti the energy
infrastructure regulatory functions
moving department of energy obviously
that would include the staffing of uh at
doe
any further questions for
representative partial has a question
thank you so much
if i read this bill i do like this i
should add i think there's a lot of
cleaning up here that happens but the
one thing that i'm still stumbling on is
this um
certificate for boundary the like i'm
seeing that
um
in the case like a wind uh system on
line 21
we're talking about after you add up the
cost from line 19 to 20
21 and 26 i assume that applies as well
we're talking about 168 thousand dollars
uh as opposed to 87 200 for a
coal or oil fueled factory
um
i must really
i would love to get an answer on this
yep no you have my commitment i'm gonna
uh
go back to commissioner scott who was
puc commissioner at the time and we'll
know the history of where the
the reasoning behind the amounts i i do
believe there was a formula involved
based on
um how much it would cost to follow up
on these but um and i i know it had it
wasn't based on
a policy initiative to
um
support one
fuel versus another one energy source
versus another um but let me get you the
the right answer on
how those
um values per megawatt were determined
um where where the the figures came from
and uh
the commissioner won't mind me
committing on his behalf we'll get that
back to you because i i i can uh i
wasn't here for the original and and i
want to make sure you get the right
answer for someone who was here when
this was developed
representative pementel has a question
thank you mister
thank you
thank you mr chairman thank you uh
mr sanborn
on the same subject
you cannot ask commissioner scott about
uh line 26
because that's a totally new line yeah
so
if you could maybe figure out well
actually i can because uh we were part
of the committee to draft this and um
and i also think uh at the time diane
martin was still chair
so i i can
um
i'm going to go back and get some
reasoning of where the original numbers
came from and where that new line five
came from as well thank you the
reasoning for that thank you
okay uh remember to turn your microphone
off
if you're not speaking
uh representative mcgee thank you mr
chairman thank you mr sanborn for taking
my question
um my question is around you said you
gave good a good explanation of what
you're thinking is going to happen going
forward with hb2 and changes in funding
makes sense
and i like the idea that you're saying
you know the sec is kind of floating out
here and it really doesn't have the
resources to do what it's supposed to do
because it's not a regular thing
which makes sense all of that makes
sense to me
the the question i have is around the
how we will find somebody to head up the
sec because
um
it seems like
that agency maybe more than any other
is regulatory in nature in terms of
being sort of the
the gatekeeper
for
sighting of projects and so
i'm wondering if there has been any
discussion around how you find that
person that's
the right person because the bright red
line which we talk about a lot
since the doe came in trying to figure
out what is that line between
executive agency functions and
regulatory burden
if you could just say anything about
whether there have been any
conversations um in ges on that piece or
in in you know in your work on this yeah
sure um
a couple points on that um number one as
i admitted last time uh we've had a lot
of challenges uh recruiting we we
pursued a few folks who at the end
thought there were better professional
opportunities for them
for themselves
i will say this
the bright red line
in for this position actually
it's more about
the
puc and the sec commissioners
not being able to
discuss
matters there uh
anything before them versus between them
and the doe because
the sec
is really
attached to the um puc now it's it's not
other than uh you know the department of
energy i think being now one of the
members um
uh
there isn't so much the the bright red
line um that needs to exist between the
p you see
and the new department of energy
um
because the the functions are so
separate
um that part of it's not really
concerning what's concerning is
uh i think to your broader point this is
it requires um
you know a lawyer is
the best candidate a lawyer with energy
background
it would be the most ideal candidate um
at its salary
having one with a lot of experience
is challenging giving private sector
salaries right now for folks for
equivalent folks
and the other challenges is you're a
staff of one yes you have the other
commissioners and you do have some of
the structure of the puc to to assist
you but um you're you're a staff of one
so
um you do have to be you know in hiring
you do have to find someone who um you
have a lot of confidence in their
ability to
uh juggle all these balls you know uh
with no staff assistance
so
follow up
and the follow-up would be i guess you
know
the concern i have uh i'm just being
frank is independence right because if a
person is an island if they're all by
themselves as the head of a department
and they're reliant on the department
around them then the influence in the
decision-making is
seems like it could be
it could become less independent than it
might be if there were not
that particular structure so i guess i'm
just concerned about the structure
i
so all i can say is as i said in my
testimony last week and i'll reiterate
this week uh again this one i'm kind of
speaking just as an individual involved
in this um i too am very concerned about
the structure which is why i was so
supportive of last week's bill creating
a study to look at totally reforming it
um i i think given the nature of these
and you know my experience now in the
offshore wind um these regulatory
responsibilities need a state agency not
a ad hoc group of folks who this is
a secondary responsibility with no staff
no support so i i too the structure very
much concerns me um i don't think it
uh fits uh for 2002 and the importance
of energy infrastructure and why
uh i'll lend my voice on hopefully ideas
of um of reforming the sec so that um
energy infrastructure can be permitted
and regulated uh similar to are the
other regulatory functions of the
state so i i to share your structure but
i also i'm very concerned that groups of
citizens have been waiting
two years now for responses to their
concerns of existing projects that have
already been deployed and they haven't
had any response so
within the structure we have
uh myself and commissioner scott as the
vice chair we'll do everything we can to
at least use what we have to try and
address um our fellow citizens concerns
out there thank you my concern was
wasn't structured my concern was that
the structure maintained independence of
the decisions yeah so
i i um
again i too you are not the first person
to point out that concern
um other members of this committee have
that concern
um again which goes back to it still is
kind of a structural question though
because a better structure would
improve independence and
some of the legislation you'll see
is
geared around
um a single individual not having so
much autonomy to make a decision
themselves
again which
short term we'll do the best we can with
the structure we have and the dynamic we
have and long term
uh
why improvements to the overall
structure i think would be beneficial
thank you
i'd like to
advise members of the committee that i
just forwarded to all of you
a link to an article that was written by
tom goetz in new hampshire business
review
about what a reorganization of the site
evaluation committee might look like and
he suggested in that article i
urge you all to read it
that
going forward
the site evaluation committee might
actually disappear altogether
and that
it would be replaced by
an office of energy siting in the
department of energy
and the adjudicative responsibility
would be taken over by the puc
so essentially the puc would become
the site evaluation committee
and with administrative support from the
department of energy
that is very likely
the
the course that the study committee
should it be signed into law that looks
at the future of the sec that's very
likely the direction it will take
to move toward a structure such as that
that will be
probably the first
avenue that the study study committee
will explore and if it looks like that
will work then that's probably what will
will be the recommendation for hb2 for
next for 2023
okay any further questions did you have
a question representative callie pitts i
didn't have a question i i had a comment
and i i think probably it doesn't belong
here neither did the last discussion
wasn't part of the
i i think that the fee structure that
people were questioning
was put in
that the puc the sec was supposed to be
autonomous and those fees were supposed
to
cover what it cost
investigate and study exactly what was
going to happen with each project
and if you took it each project and you
looked at say the nuclear project
that's 1200 megawatts
so it's going to take more time
more
more looking into more consultants
so i think that's was part of the basis
that the the p the sec should be
autonomous and that rate payers should
not
bear that cost but the industries that
wanted to pursue these projects should
bear them and that was my understanding
way back when
yeah i think that's that's correct and
what i'm going to investigate is
what determined the
the amounts for each type of
activity where where
uh how that was determined and um
as you can tell from my testimony i to
share uh
the uh the suggestion of the article uh
that the chairman mentioned is uh very
much in line with what i would think
would make a lot more sense in today's
day um given uh
just
quite frankly the broken structure of
the sec
okay representative callie pitts don't
forget to turn your microphone off when
you're no i don't i want to be heard
because the puc
is funded by the ratepayers and the sec
shouldn't be
it isn't
it's funded by the application fees
yeah these activities would be
pardoned
no i mean there are parts of the
many parts of the permitting process
that des has funded is funded through
fees
um the fish and game
permitting functions are permitted are
funded through fees so the fees in the
industry could even under the structure
the chairman mentioned fees could still
fund those activities and the burden
still wouldn't go to the ratepayer so
even even the puc functions you could
fund
anything related to the adjudicative to
this to be paid for from the fund that
is supported by industry fees so you
could have all of the current activities
put in better parts and better able
parts of the state government and still
all funded by industry applications and
fees and not
uh ratepayers
representative loki you had a question
or a comment um thank you
might there be a point to all of this
where
some of these activities cover an awful
lot of real estate uh if you know for
instance northern pass would impact
most of the state
and whereas if you put a uh
combined cycle natural gas plant down
kerplunk it's just you know a few acres
and there's that would seem to be a
significant variable that the site
evaluation committee yeah i
i i think everyone who's mentioned
the reasoning are all
you put them together and it's it's all
the
the answer was they figured out a
formula of what the cost per megawatt
was
and associated the fee structure based
on those and um i'm just what i'm going
to do is confirm
where those numbers came from and then
i'll also confirm go back in our notes
about why we came up with the number
1200 for the new line five
okay anything further for mr sanborn
we appreciate you being here assistant
commissioner of des thank you very much
we have one more person who would like
to speak to us before we leave this
public hearing and that's john tuthill
so mr tuthill
please let us hear your comments
john's hot hill awkward sullivan county
um
the parking meter is going to run out in
about one and a half minutes so that's
what i'm going to try to take
um
this is perhaps non-germane but we were
speaking earlier about landfills there's
not a capacity crisis in new hampshire
for new hampshire generated waste and
it's going to be a good decade if not
more it has occurred to me
that with projects on the scale of a
recent proposal in the north country
on a 2 000 acre property
uh where the first phase of that the
first three phases in fact which are
part of a incomplete permit application
before des
you'd be looking at revenues in excess
of a billion dollars these are very very
large projects and i think we've gotten
to the point now
where uh having something like the site
evaluation committee
with multiple agencies participating
considering
um citing of these
these projects which are in essence
utilities at this point i mean that's
not how they're regulated in fact they
really are not regulated from a business
point of view
um
but
i think we've gotten um to where there's
a near monopoly monopoly on waste
disposal services in the state with two
two very very large corporations
multi-billion dollar corporations one of
them global
um so that was just an idea i'd like to
put out here if we're going to be doing
some long long term thinking about the
role of the sec
i would be very interested in including
uh the sighting of these major
industrial facilities uh
something for the sec to consider thank
you very much
thank you
yeah yeah i hope you make your parking
meter i'll send you the bill if i don't
know
okay
that exhausts the number of people who
want to speak on this so representative
mick williams can you give us the blue
sheet
this is senate bill
429 we had six in support 25 opposed
zero neutral it's open until midnight
okay thank you with that i will close
the public hearing on house uh senate
bill 429
and now we will have a discussion about
tomorrow's executive session
i have identified nine bills that we can
exact tomorrow
and uh we will do so
starting at the conclusion
of the public hearing on the last bill
tomorrow which i believe is senate bill
271.
so the nine bills we will exec tomorrow
will be
senate bill 256
senate bill 440 fn
senate bill 259
senate bill 261-fn
senate bill 264.
senate bill
268-fn
senate bill 269-fn
senate bill 270
and senate bill
424-f n
but we will start that probably
with a little bit of luck around
3 30
and uh
we'll go until
we'll go as late as we have to to get
them all done
because i want all of those bills to be
heard or on the house floor on
april 21st so when we exec them tomorrow
i'm going to ask that all
majority and minority reports
be ready to go
by wednesday
at noon
okay
representative pimentel
thank you mr chairman um will you
consider
like filling ins
we we have
four hearings tomorrow
um
a fifth bill got added so there's bill
got added okay
and that's why it's going to three
all right
i was just wondering
uh if you would be filling in on the
execs
well what we will do
um
if if a bill scheduled for nine o'clock
for example finishes at 9 45 we'll try
to squeeze in an exact session on one
bill
before the the next bill starts at 10
o'clock
but
i need the cooperation of all of you to
make that happen you've got to reduce
the number of questions you ask so that
we can get through these public hearings
more quickly so that we can have time
to do that
if we if we can if we can do that we can
get through this at a reasonable hour
otherwise we might be here till five six
seven who knows tomorrow night
representative
thomas
uh thank you mr uh yes i'm i'm glad you
said that i would make a suggestion in
lieu of the heavy schedule we will have
tomorrow
in so far as making your questions
make them succinct please
and can we also put a note out to ask
the
speakers that please
answer the question
not to
bring about five minutes of discussion
that might be
peripheral to it
yes we will we will
make that intrigue entreaty to the uh
people who come to testify tomorrow that
they keep their answers succinct as well
representative samsic
uh yes mr chairman i think you mentioned
that tomorrow our last bill would be 271
wouldn't it be 321
why
actually now i think 44.48 448 yeah okay
that's right okay
and you're right 321 does come after 271
okay so thank you
um
representative callie pitts
i just want to say that i'm going to
why i ask questions at the public
hearing is because we know we're not
going to have subcommittees or another
chance or another opportunity
to question and that's why i think some
of the questions are a little protracted
from my point of view
okay that's fine
does uh one other thing that i should
mention representative plett as we
uh spoke about earlier today is in
mexico
and representative notter who left early
today has to go to new york tomorrow for
the funeral of her uncle
and so neither of them will be in
attendance tomorrow and the
republican office
the
has supplied or is supplying substitutes
for both of those members for the
executive session
uh are there any missing persons from
the
will there be any missing persons from
the on the democratic side
i'll make you make sure you do that
promptly because there's supposedly
there's supposed to be 24 hours notice
but
okay
anything else
great day today good work everybody we
got through them all
i think we're ready to go
see you tomorrow nine o'clock
yep